[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
yes sir
yes sir
sunday y'all know what it is
it's the lord's day
what's going on how my levels are
sounding
what's going on lord metroid what's
going on
lost forever player or lost ever plays
my bad
none name available salute gerald mack
the legend what's going on let me know
how my levels of sound death mobile i
see you lydian master i see you fifth
horseman v what's going on gerald says
i'm clear that's what i'm talking about
hustle that's what i'm talking about dc
what's going on dj oros with the wrench
my man happy lord's day salute you
already know the besties in the building
black
conflict x let's go
you know what i'm saying i lost landed
on you
no doubt what's going on man we
definitely out here so
big show big show we got griggity
coming through
judah 144 what's going on i'm good bro
i'm glad i'm trying to do as best as i
can man been a crazy week crazy week hi
max what's going on ray palmer what's up
cory mosey what's up
[Music]
if you want to really be the best you
got to go get that advanced gg they got
that best tea
right now that promotion you know what
i'm saying get that you see you see it
tag the top iron lord 30. you know what
i'm saying get focused while you're at
work or if you're about to go to the gym
you bout to hit the hockey rink dj go
hit that energy yeah i'm in my promo bag
awful grim bones what's going on here
for logic with the soldier what's going
on
yeah man yeah sunday
should be a fun one we definitely gotta
talk also and give our flowers to the
legendary
cow
l
super pod shots tick
oh gee in the game we gotta give them
flowers today a little bit you know what
i'm saying it was just uh wow what a
what a crazy time and everybody's
surprised by that loss but it is what it
is and um we will talk about it you know
we gotta celebrate it man that's why all
the petty beefing and you see i stay out
of that because at the end of the day
it's like
life is short you know what i mean like
life is really short
you have to appreciate people even if we
disagree people disagree with me all the
time you know one thing you realize is
that at any moment you know what i'm
saying a person is gone and
yo you make it right make it right it's
not none of this stuff is worth it man
we play video games all that beef and
even i had a little thing with kyle at
one point
you know did this nonsense you know
saying we get it it's you know what i'm
saying i'm glad i made peace with my
brother
and um we'll talk about it i got a lot
to say obviously it hits home
so um but anyway i appreciate y'all in
here on a large day sunday we're gonna
have some gaming uplift the spirit you
know what i'm saying and have some fun
so look let me go get greggitty
king will be pulling up with music and
content strikes
hopefully some can make it i miss off
and add it could pull up in a few too so
i'll see y'all
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that
again you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel dramatical
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell an uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the
snapple and making it flammable this is
that
this
love my city but i'm still by coastal i
got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
who
let's do it
[Music]
is
[Music]
wolf but then they will mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that you can't even still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday is suitable
[Music]
on the lord's day
[Music]
we cannot be flexing like this all right
here you hear ye and we are live welcome
to the iron laws podcast llc and also
live on lords of gaming.net episode
number 248 it's another glorious sunday
we're back at the round table on the
lord's date i'm very excited about our
special guest and we got microsoft as
metacritic's highest rated publisher
oh lord so
so these recent state of play
playstation's future and perfect dark to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose
combination of humor and passion for the
xbox brand has truly made him one of the
most highly requested guest at the round
table
whether it's living a day in the life as
an xbox guy series or being the
occasional provocateur with his youtube
videos
introducing the creator of the dirk
griggity youtube channel and the host of
the wbg xbox podcast
the lord of organic growth
fire hip hop beats
and of course shinmu
who always reminds us to hit the like
button
live from motown detroit and making his
debut into the realm of the lord
my man lord dirk griggity how we doing
sir what is going on man thank you for
the introduction my brother i can't
believe i'm here man this is like a
dream of mine brother i'm here with the
lords man
thank you for having me mal truly
appreciate it man oh much love brother
you've been doing your thing man again
you know shout out to attic because um
every once in a while we'll do this
thing where it's like yo we want
different people in the community not
always oh who's the top who got the most
subscribers and you know
you know i mean like sometimes you gotta
you know do that and he does feelers and
probably your name came up
so many times and they were like when i
might
get it i might lowkey say i do that for
the community but i do that so i don't
have to look for people
shout out there it kind of is like you
know you guys scratched my black eye
scratches
shout out to the community man but for
right now
for real your day came up brother it's
cool to have you around what you been
playing man man you know what i um i
started playing elder ring at launch i
kind of got you know step back a little
bit i have to
really focus on that game take my time
and focus on the gaming there's so many
other games i'm playing at the moment i
said okay let me finish this downlight
too first like wwe
came out i love that game so far you
know i'm always playing 2k so i'm going
to you know those are three games i'm
playing right now i'm going to
eventually go back to el nino when i get
the chance but that's about it man no
doubt man salute salute yeah everybody
rocking it even king rocking that right
crazy yeah man i'm about to be nasty no
doubt but
on a different note man i gotta set it
off before we do our normal intro and
stuff um huge loss in the community huge
loss um first it was our brother we lost
our brother demi games not too long ago
and shout out for him with level one gay
men fame and the crew very cool dude and
then uh we gotta give our flowers to cal
cal-l
super paw shots tick podcasts
probably and me and atticus talk about
it one of the best solo podcasters in
the game like as far as controlling the
mic by yourself
and hosting the show people go ahead
people don't know how hard that is yes
that that is extremely hard like i've
gotten better at it but cal be making it
seem like a simple one yeah and it just
engage an audience and just flow that
that's a that's a microphone controller
that that's that's a host you know what
i mean and as a fellow host i always
respected that about him you know what
i'm saying and you know for for us you
know it was the media influence he
showed cats elaine how to be
professional you know on with tick
podcast the website and everything and
um when i always felt one of his
greatest achievements was having phil
spencer on before any outlet absolutely
yeah i didn't know any outlet that had
phil on and to see it you know what i'm
saying of course i'm a man of color so
it did it hit different for me you know
just to see it and um you know i just
want to send a recipe shout out in the
realm to him
you know his wife his beautiful children
and um we're all in shock we're hurt it
was very sudden shout out to the crew
shout out to b money shout out to
anchorman the original tick you know
what i'm saying that brought us on and
gave us a platform at one point we was
over there so i just wanted to say that
giving us flowers and i know the
community's hurting but um we're never
going to forget your brother and um i
just it will open it up for the rest of
the crew if anybody want to say anything
real quick you know for cal but uh
definitely a huge loss in the community
absolutely cal you know regardless
obviously a lot of you guys know that
you know we used to be over there on on
that platform you know
creative differences but
one thing that you can never
say you can never take away from cow is
the passion that man had like he's one
of the few people that i could talk to
about games and i know it's never going
to go to some console war stuff it's
never going to it's ever going to go
left it's just going to strictly be
about talking about games and i'm going
to miss that man because a lot of people
don't know but
cal was almost
in the spot where hustle is yeah i
almost made cow facts the the co-host uh
but i was testing people out and
you know uh because i always thought cal
was like
he in podcasting limits like
he was second to a to none in terms of
the way he did podcast it's just like
you know
it's just it's sad man because
regardless what
was going on
you know it's sad that you know i didn't
i didn't i uh man i don't even know what
to say like it's just it's just sad that
something like that happened it's just
so sudden like a lot of the times you
know something's gonna happen
but it's just like one day i i thought
it was a joke i woke up like you know
those those dumb tweets where people put
some dumb
posts at the end they're like a retweet
to see what people think of you i
thought that's what they were saying
about him and i was like oh man like and
it's just like it hit me hard like i
didn't i just sat there for a second and
i just looked at the screen and i was
like
that sucks like because
no it's just
absolutely felt so sudden so sudden that
was the thing about it yeah man and soft
king i don't know if you want to see
anyone before we move on well i mean
there's always a a big loss in a um when
you lose a boss he was a boss
so you know
um
regardless for anything he's uh a
stand-up dude uh
inspirational
pioneer yes you know and a family man so
uh you know at the end of the day
regardless of what is his children
that have to you know um you know
remember their dad so he has a lot of
video he has a lot of stuff that he left
back for his family to see to go back to
get to know their dad
you know to know exactly what he's about
and you know how positive he was and you
know listen
like you said he recognized you know
phil dominance max
he definitely did he loved when you did
that
he loved you before anybody else did and
you know um like he he was a definite
boss so it's very few bosses that you
have out here that are doing
multitasking as far as websites far as
you know um
talking to talk and walking to walk but
you know a respectable stand-up dude so
it's a huge loss when you lose a boss no
doubt and as you said we got to give i
want to you know you mentioned phil
dominance we gotta give phil some
respect for forgiving callus flower that
was huge that was huge man like you know
that would have meant so much to cal you
know i mean because again the
relationship and everything and like i
said being one of the first so for him
to acknowledge the community was was big
but salva gave you you know dirt i don't
know if you have any final words before
we move forward yeah yeah i mean uh
again like
when we started out you know he was the
one it was kind of a sparring match
between him and dizzy kind of for the
lord they they both saw kind of
something in the lords from the
beginning and you know they wanted that
on their platform and you know like
attic said you know we had some creative
differences or whatever but at the end
of the day
um all of that was kind of squashed you
know yeah later then and at the end of
the day we all have for the love of the
games that's it and you know and and i
think a lot something that we've learned
over the years is to really
do our best especially on this platform
to
to
put each other up and above and not put
each other down and i think
i think you know
through our relationship with him or
whatever i think a lot of the community
has seen that like over the years you
know whatever you might have little head
butting or whatever but at the end of
the day we're all here for the same
reason and once we understand that we're
here to to to pick each other up yep
that's that's when things get really
beautiful and i think you know again i
hadn't had communication with kyle for
the longest time but again i saw that he
was on addict's show for for a couple of
times he uh he recently made some funny
posts about cog looking like the new
yeah yeah
he got me
i was laughing yeah yeah i was like
he ain't wrong
it seemed like he was making this kind
of his way back into the community again
i don't know what happened but
um that is a huge huge loss again
because a lot of
the blueprint for how we do stuff came
from from tick and and again that idea
of like this guy has filled on his
platform yeah it's a lot a lot of people
could say we're like a spiritual
successor yeah and a lot a lot of people
have to be real a lot of people who
found us from this platform we were very
strong
and that gave us a little bit more
exposure and showed dudes how to really
move professionally if you want to be
immediate exactly what i'm saying but
yeah it was yeah it was that that first
packs that we went under the brand yeah
like you know we've said it in the in
the past like the podcast was almost
done before that like there was
conversations before that pax and that
packs we really saw like
like the
we saw goals that the potential one yeah
starting to come into the line
that's one breathe life back into it
yeah we could never take that from dirt
rest of peace my brother i hope you know
again we're going to continue to do
everything we can to you know
make you proud you know
and uh condolences to your family man no
doubt no doubt dare i give you fine well
absolutely man you know back when i was
just a guy in the chat you know just
starting to listening
to youtube found this community he was
one of the first chinese pro xbox
channels that i found in this community
and i was so impressed when he
interviewed phil spence i don't know if
it was 2014 or 2015. but it was
wow i was like wow
oh man that was amazing to me and seeing
him and his crew go to e3 and all of
those things i was just like this guy is
doing amazing things and like you said
he was like the blueprint for a lot yes
of us you know like guys that's on
youtube pro xbox challenge that's doing
their thing and um
shout out to him man yeah for sure sam i
can load us this to his family because i
know it's rough man i know it's it's a
it's a rough spot and the guys know and
he reached out to me
a few years ago i had a much smaller
channel to you know to be a guest on his
podcast
wow really me you know just like thank
you brother so shout out to him man rest
in peace my brother rest in peace
brother salute you already know your
powers
i've already go rest in power you
already know and uh you know we got the
four horsemen of gaming the original
lawsuit around here at the round table
my calls for the co-most my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
of the attic show how we doing sir
doing pretty good man i've been playing
a lot of that triangle strategy game
i will say that who have you sacrificed
sir
i really have no idea there's no
permadeath in this one right i don't
think there's no there's not there's not
i do think that's one of the biggest
takeaways from this game
i you know i'm going to spoil a little
bit of review and i would recommend
buying something else
it's not glowing it's not it's not off
the product it's not off the product
it's i feel like there's other products
that do what this game sets out to do
just as good if not better yeah
for example and they're octopatch no
this is a different type of gameplay
than often
uh
and it's like half the price like
because i gotta judge it as a 60
retail okay
and it's a good game so far and i'm
going to go into big detail on my review
probably beginning next week but it's
just in terms of that 60 man you know
and i would say wait for sale but it's a
nintendo game we ain't getting
or you can wait for it to come to that
game pass when uh when it comes to uh
xbox like octopath traffic
yeah
don't get bamboozled like i did
[Laughter]
that
yeah and uh it's it's
that's all i've really besides the raid
which you know i don't want to go into
that because i have a feeling yeah
that's a podcast in itself
he has a spicy take over he got a spicy
taste
me too yeah spicy taste yeah it's good
we'll save it
dj orange dj come up he said whoa whoa
whoa
dj was in the club i do want to point
out that when uh remember a couple years
ago when
uh you guys were trying to use lukewarm
as a good uh as a good phrase and yes
and i said no one uses lukewarm as a
good phrase
and everyone on the podcast said i was
tripping i said lukewarm and you guys
are automatically assumed
it's a very diplomatic way of saying
whack
it's a diplomatic whack yo i'm done with
you
i think lukewarm means it's just it's it
is what it is average like it's nothing
special
moving on from the slant and of course
we have the most technical gaming lord
the solo gaming list for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sastradamus the lord of clarity and lord
patron of the iron bank sorely missed my
man you're sovereign how are you doing
bro what's good man what's good man my
apologies apprehend this guy
no no but then we did we have them in
shackles
as it turns out it was probably some
young hooligans just breaking glass
we put them in a group home what what do
we do with these little hooligans
let's let's just say it won't be
bothering anyone ever again okay fair
enough we've been taking care of jeffrey
has handled it
i just want to point out that i will not
go to court so if i get subpoenaed
who reached out and see everything was
cool but everything was great uh you
know thankfully nothing's stolen we
don't really keep anything of value in
the car but you know you just never know
and uh so it was good but now you get
away with your switch yo you
stupid he said nothing about it
[Music]
so yeah that that situation is handled
and i had a bit of a of a medical
situation during the course of the week
that uh you know listen uh you know
talking about talking about you know
unfortunate things like people passing
what not um guys some of us are getting
a little bit up there in age or whatever
we got to take care of ourselves man we
really got to take care of ourselves
like it's not it's not even a game out
here like you know
people that are very young man like very
young and something happened to me this
year yeah oh no no no
listen i i don't i don't have any qualms
about being straight up for what happens
to me i had i had a kidney stone
never in my life
and i thought i was going to die yes i
didn't know what was going on i had no
no sort of
context for this happening to me
previously so i was like oh i'm dying i
don't know what's going on
you know what's crazy
i know people that have kidney stones
like yearly it seems like
oh
so um yeah man
so it just it puts
these guys will tell you there was a
point that was born in time i was the
biggest beast in the gym like an animal
in the gym i remember and i fell off and
and when you fall off
certain other aspects of your diet
everything started to changes and i'm
like nope and you know with my work
hours it's very easy to be like nah i'm
not gonna do that now i'm not gonna do
that
oh no man this this this kind of writing
[ __ ] this is the pepsi oh complete
complete got done son got done
and the funny thing for me is that i'm
really good i don't touch that stuff
monday through friday but the weekend
hits i'm like party time
[Laughter]
yeah it's a wrap so um yeah so that so
uh games that i've been playing
um
so i've been playing more horizon
forbidden west um
enjoying it but at least to this point
it still feels like it's just the core
tenets of the first one which is it
makes sense just just and bigger just
there's more of it right
and i'm enjoying it the game is gorgeous
but it still has that thing it's like
damn it there's something about it it's
just i don't know what the hell it is
[Music]
the thing is yo i was in the beasties
like fight with these robots the other
day and it's like
when it comes down to it it's getting
the right arrows shooting off the the
the you know the parts on them right
rolling out of the way when they attack
you it was it was this this repetition
that just
i just it was muscle memory from the
first game it just so far it just
doesn't feel new in that way yeah it
what is it a diplomatic way of saying
yo
wow
no
but um
13 of people that finished
because i know the story is probably
crazy like the first one so i really
want to get through that um then i've
been playing this this nda game that you
guys haven't
heard about um but i'm gonna break nba
right now oh elgin ring
yo you're stupid
i was like yeah he got paid
i don't know about
that
i'm like yo we we live visiting this
game
this is like the third week that i've
not been able to talk about elden really
so real quick um
yeah elder ring
i gotta there's gonna be conversations
around this you know me my feelings on
zelda
and breath of the wild or whatever i
think what eldon ring
what elder ring does right when i played
zelda i didn't realize that that
climbing was so integral to that feeling
that that feeling of like of just
openness and just being able to do
whatever elder ring doesn't have that
right and it doesn't you know in some
ways it doesn't have the the scripted
density of a witcher 3 or something like
that or even the density of a grand
theft auto game
but
what it makes up for that in just the
sheer
amount of crazy stuff that you have no
idea is coming at you from every corner
and it's the the true idea of discovery
in that game
with coupled with terror because you
don't know what's around the corner
coupled with pure fear of fear is is is
something i've not felt in any open
world game before so
it's up there with those games it really
is before we pass you you're talking
it's up there with them yeah i'm not
even close to putting that there
in terms of like because the other ones
i i have considerably more time in
what games
oh this is a breath of the wild with
your three like but specifically eldon
ring up there
me personally this destroys breath of
the wild oh
we're talking about i could i could i
can see i see all right
you're recently biased
it feels like this we know how he feels
when it comes to the opal world filling
i just didn't feel like it's a good
zelda zelda game right but the thing is
like this game like
i don't maybe it's because of the broken
like everything breaks on that game so
kind of like some of the immersion of
like really getting the feel of one
weapon because you're constantly on the
switch yeah but like this game
it's just like what i will literally
spend an hour knowing i'm supposed to go
this way i'm supposed to to go this way
to get there i'm like nah i'm gonna go
down the hill i'm gonna see what's good
and i'm gonna go down the hill i'm not
what's funny is i was hoping smooth last
week with something and and uh i was
sitting there because i was watching
tick tock and i uh after i did the uh
the royal capital someone put on tick
tock a easier way of getting to the
bottom floor
and i'm sitting there and i'm like
smooth you want to do a quicker way you
want to do like an hour and a half away
he's like obviously he's gonna say
quicker one yeah so he's sitting there
and i just jump off the back and he's
like would you where'd you go and i you
found like this little chandelier midway
between you and the ground and then i
jumped from there down to the bottom the
last bit of the way and i was like
smooth i know it looks hard you just
jump straight for the actual
building and you'll get there man he
fought he he jumps didn't know where i
was he just jumped assuming he didn't
know where to jump he wasn't jumping
straight to the floor and died
yeah
i was talking to king yesterday about it
oh the day before yesterday yesterday
yeah and we would talk about like
the thing that this game really retains
from other souls games is the fact that
when you go into a situation
there's always some scheist in the
situation
i think you see what's in front of you
right and then but there'll be two
enemies in the corner
[Laughter]
to creep into every situation it's like
all right i went into this cave and i
saw these wolves and this is really like
you saw these walls and i see the water
it was too focused on the white wolf
yeah exactly
wolves in front of him he didn't know
like when he jumped off the ledge right
under the ribs
[Laughter]
in the bushes
i died right there same thing i'm done
the famous i killed undead soldier
because i i'm like oh that's easy xp and
turns into a big giant bear so yeah it's
like they literally deliberately put me
in a situation where i'm trying to get
free runes but instead getting free
runes like i got i got destroyed yeah
and we're talking about the bears that
you fight like mid-game i'm fighting at
the beginning like i have still no
chance
and the the bears are is one of the few
things in the game that like you can't
outrun no oh
this game is the epitome of the of the
term
they giveth and they take away
everything everything that you
everything that helps you in some way
shape or form will impact you in a
negative way some way shape or form to
create this this sense of balance
where sometimes the balance isn't even
in your face it's never in your favor
really
but it is that thing of like just be
just be careful
what you wish for be careful what you
what you think as a is a positive
because in some way shape or form it'll
come back to bite you
and that's the beauty of miyazaki like
it's like it's fair kind of
but
but you're gonna have to get over that
hump uh i'm enjoying i just i enjoy
getting beat up by this this game in
particular seriously
selling this to me
it's gotta enjoy
when it comes to when it comes to like
elder ring like when you die
you 100 pretty much know okay that was
my fault
like you'll be going around like the map
and you'll see those big two trolls
being dressed like they'll have chains
jammed in their back and they're
carrying a k uh like some kind of cherry
around like and if you kill them
yeah if you kill them you get something
in the back of the chair so it's just
like it's it's a unique game man so
that's what it's up
yeah that's about it that is all about
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the access gamer oh the
prophet of xbox
swami
kings of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how are we doing sir
i'm doing great but my man lemon's doing
better oh yeah
oh wow
my man lemon happy birthday my dude i'm
sorry i couldn't be at your surprise
birthday party but right now we're still
doing 30 days of coach
this is this many faces
please tell me you didn't just tell this
man he has a surprise birthday party no
he already had it he already had it he
already had that that was
yesterday that they they got him yeah
my god
it reminds me of a video i saw a tech
talk where a dude comes in he's like man
he's like you you you pretty late to
your own surprise birthday party it
turns out he just sat down on his porch
for a minute to do something he's like
surprise birthday party like
nah you're good he's good
what's going on
oh man it's uh it's been fantastic i've
been in my my my 80s bag um
something crazy
been uh
you know mason all that stuff so you
know filling my home and all that let's
see
remember follow him on the rise
oh it's kind of crazy so i went upstairs
and i was going through the coach and i
was like
what epitomizes that hustle that flow
that
that money ain't a thing situation and i
was like oh you fat farm you up it was
like thank you god i'm ready
i came downstairs and you know you know
for my man dirt
it is what it is we gonna do what we
gonna do today baby but um
first i gotta give this the dirt uh this
is for you oh
before elder ring man this is it for you
no no no no no no
i didn't say i played it before i said
elder ring is a game i'm going to have
to focus on oh okay so i said i'm going
to put it
you know in the backlog for a second you
put it all the way
a lot of people are saying that wwwe
games like the best game they've had in
years and years yeah it is
i'll wait for that to hit game pass
[Laughter]
yo so you know all right so y'all nudes
know i'm this super game pass dude this
is not a gay pass i don't care shout out
to phil dominus maximus aurelius for
giving me guardians of the galaxy yeah
swords went out and paid for guess who
got that joy for the easy freezie
so it pays the weight but i knew elder
ring wasn't going good yeah what
happened why you ain't waiting for that
yeah no no we ain't playing that game
with this this right now see last week i
told addict
um slow down pump them brakes on that uh
game of the year yeah he was very
disrespectful i was like man you wilding
you in the moment right now you holistic
mm-hmm this man might be honest
oh
oh
yo you know how i know what it is when
the raid drop you just got the new dlc
for this that's my litmus test right
yeah definitely stay on your mind and
you got to do
so what i did was i put my joint on
offline
right i put my journal off like if i'm
online man dudes but like yo invite
invite party party hi hey right so i'm
all flying in the cut because i don't
want them to know exactly what i'm doing
so i'm playing with monkey shots
gala horn and his stuff he got a shout
out
for helping us do that stuff
um and me and monkey playing having a
good time because he went out you know
paid the 79 dollars for his joints so
yeah
here i am over here with this elder man
you know what it is when she knew
i can't with you
she got tricks that nobody else you have
never seen this
she's dangerous she's wild she's
unpredictable
you never know what she's gonna do one
minute it might be whips next thing it
might be changed you know whoa
what i'm telling you is this game ain't
what you think it is right because at
first remember i told you i was like let
me see what it turns out to be right
this is literally the most
do it yourself explore the world figure
something out on your own and when you
do
that's where the rewards come from when
you find out i had a whole bunch of
items
not using them not knowing that i can
imbue my sword with rot not knowing i
can build my sword with fire so i
learned this stuff because i got into
this dungeon with this dude and i was
just so sick and tired of him he was
beating the brakes off me so bad and i
was like i was calling different type of
summonses all type of different type of
things i'm staying away from him and
he'll kill him and then he'll turn his
attentions upon me and then i'm cowering
in the corner and i'm like this i have
lost all my rules with this dude i'm i'm
just like and i refuse you know when you
sit there i refuse to hurt you beat me
today even my my girl was like
why are you screaming at the tv because
this man ain't gonna beat me today you
know who else had that mentality
i was told that solid rev was fighting
one of the bosses and he said he refuses
to end that stream until he beats that
boss he was streaming till the next
morning
i started reading the items that i did
have
and this says
you take that long to to read the item
no you know what you're running around
the world you're just picking up things
and when you get to the crafting table
and something like that and when
something i'm used to other games
going through and teaching you what
you're not dead there's no hay holding
yes yeah no hand-holding so plus i was
in places where i shouldn't be so i was
getting stuff that i shouldn't have
right right so i got this thing and it
was like imbued rot
so i did it and he said
[Music]
and he rubbed it on the sword i said oh
my god and my soul was glowing with that
day and you know how it's like old
karate films when you already learn to
do style and you at the end of the movie
is the last half an hour i'm gonna kill
you the boss is gonna get this work i
let the wolves out the wolves just hit
me from left to right i came up behind
him i had that knife i said [ __ ]
and then the rock took waste and i just
stood there and i just watched him die
slow hey yo
you're gonna die today buddy
satisfaction
you know what it is get the game right
you you you're gonna have to fight the
harder boss what do it take for you to
stream that again okay so okay first of
all
you don't know me son
there's some bosses on there
listen they don't know i i i don't know
who i killed
i built this crazy king this is king i
killed some of the wack bosses at the
beginning
attic is that dude that fights in
america on live tv that you see all the
time
i'm that dude that's in mexico putting
people to sleep
oh you don't know him up to the majors
okay then you actually see him asleep
yeah but but when you see him in the
major and he knocked out your favorite
fighter you figured out you want to
cover up you know who he is okay you're
the cover-up okay
you're fighting that amateur favorite
[Music]
10 items buy five items so y'all could
so i could show you i got what addict
don't got okay all right and this is
that that's the token you probably ended
the game
you probably went to meredith and did
all the stuff that you did
but i'm going to region the region any
dude
on site okay like you saw those two
giants walking with that thing he was
like i don't know about i ran and jumped
off my horse and said oh you can get
this i want what's in the bag and then i
got what's in the bag and then i know he
had 30 dudes behind them
i set the wolf's out on them and i went
to work on them and i told you that dude
the gold suit was going to get these
knuckles i said
he not there no more they said that chad
said you the kimbo slicer elder
[Laughter]
i'm gonna take that thank you that was
little
[Laughter]
you know what's the best part about it
is
because he is like your king what you
doing cause he want to jump in my world
to see where i'm at you know how i would
do one see how you train yeah
i'm like i'm busy
you're a little peep the style i'm busy
out here smoking dude
you keep on fronting on my style then
when you see me when you see me on the
stream when the dudes go through my
repertoire and say oh my god he beat
that dude oh my god he he walking
through regions and in the npc's is like
oh that's king get up out of here
those bears that you run from run from
me oh here we go anyway moving on is
that it sir whatever it is
it's a king shadow boxing for two hours
and of course yeah myself the gaming
ninja it's still in the damn intro see
what you got to talk with you see what
you got yourself into it
i hope you got some time set aside
because let me know brother we go long
we go long so um just spread that
brother fred that realness in the realm
of the isle feed i'll tell you what you
want to hear what you need to hear shout
out to find the duke shout out to mr
maddie play's already up right now last
day of media youtube go check that out
we had the duke's first argument solved
no
oh my goodness yeah they messed up yeah
we argued what's the better bethesda
eldest girls versus fallout we got a
little passion right
we go all right y'all you bugging you
[ __ ] but no listen to that
it was a good one also for um the
patrons they had the opportunity to
ultimate basically called xbox direct
what we want from them as far as shows
with all the studios and stuff how they
gonna handle it moving forward um shout
out to the last word
yo they're killing me shout out to he
said hey little podcast we go long stop
anyway
i think they mess with the chat today
but um yeah we had a child the last word
he bounces ty got travis and the crew we
had on the last lady legend salute to
her man she is a beast with these raids
she actually helped me get all through
on playstation
um on vine disciple raid she had heard a
crude trap i played with travis for the
first time so and we had a good argument
as addict alluded to about which raid
was the best yeah you're out of one time
i was going to say you know when it
comes to the argument on which bethesda
game was but man we ain't gonna even say
what it was yeah we didn't leave alone
no one's up it's all free ninety nine
there's one three ninety nine for people
who's up right now it was right that's
all i got
so look we got that and then um yeah i
just want to actually for me as far as
i'm playing it's just been dusty i
finally finished that with the raid
there's still more stuff after the joint
and i fired up phoenix point at it um
new dlc i said game pass y'all go check
that out his in-game pass go check out
phoenix but if you like your turn-based
strategy and then um they got some new
dlc out chaos engine a couple of dlcs we
missed attic that they've added so i
wanted to find that droid up but uh
sorry i want to get the super chats and
then we could do some promo and then get
to the patient dirt cricket he was very
patient
he he knew what he was saying he knew
but you got to be there
i know it was [ __ ] i'm the family
remember for one year thank you sir uh
he didn't say anything but thank you my
brother i appreciate it like i was right
hold on let me get sick talk about
trouble let me get kind of this boy
sinister talk about traitor because i
got the raid uh you're the first person
to jump outside the clan in the lfg you
gotta get it and get the raid and then
come back and say i'm gonna pull you
guys through so stop it anyway i had to
get him continue that's my bad shout out
to dj make sure you get it
all right cool there we go um
matt titubar member for two months shout
out to matt titchbot xbox number one
publisher king's gonna be messy today
looking forward to another five show
king and dirt combo gonna be interesting
yes
then we got jacob j 10 super chat shout
out to the lords of my homie dirk great
to see my youtube worlds cross have a
great show no
what's up jake jay
it's the homie right there man no doubt
absolutely now we got raiden blade five
pound super chat hello iron lords it's
sunday the lord's day and welcoming my
wbg and tts bro dirt ray tracing blue
rickety
yeah yeah hey hey there was time on my
head silly see rachel yo
your head is i'm done
welcome to the house of the lords dirt
and cake no doubt
we got the homie italian clowns remember
for one you remember for 14 months
absolutely thank you my brother dropping
in to say hello to the iron lords much
love same to you brother you already
know
and we have cucumber five pounds
you know how your fans do so yeah
[Laughter]
we gotta hear what this is a song
segment
cow no doubt my brother
without yeah
then we got kendrick starr two dollars
super chat what up dirk tts yeah what up
brother what's happening
there we got 108 dragons five dollar
super chat good afternoon to my brothers
good to see the homie dirt on the show
tts no doubt lemon what's up bro
yes
[Laughter]
who is that the greatest of lemons
the most powerful lemons
[Applause]
he
[Laughter]
thank you sir salute much love to
everyone rip to cal he was one of the
first podcasters i listened to love to
his fam absolutely man factual
then we have brian lane i jumped a
little bit so if you you see yours is
out of order it's there though okay um
brian lane five dollar super chat what
ilp merch do i need to buy to get cog to
play elden ring get them likes up hmm
baby
hey
pax you know that iron lord 30 or
advanced gg there's a lot of things you
can do
you know what do the advanced gg stuff
but give him that um the iron lords pack
stuff
because um
yeah i would love to see that i mean how
about i mean we could we could do we
could do a little uh we can do a little
survey in the chat like oh
time
yeah let's do this moving on moving on
how many times
[Laughter]
out here looking like a fancy tuskegee
airman
g-unit
listen happy birthday
there we go no taco five dollars with a
chat
sony don't know how to make sequels and
still innovate outside of naughty dog
wait for breath of the wild too for a
great innovative sequel
of course
then we have flame five dollar super
chat hello my name is little bo flame
and i've lost my sleep can someone help
me find my extra hour of sleep it went
missing in the dead of night what the
hell is flame talking the flame is loose
playing elden ring i guess
so some dudes forgot that the hours
spring ahead and you lose that oh
then we have kendrick star five dollars
elden ring popularizes bad game design
bad onboarding bad story bad quests
as long as combat is good anyone can get
good at a bad game with enough time
jesus you know what you might be on this
one
i feel like you're heartbroken that your
horizon is in the bushes but um you're
gonna have to live with that part of
that 13 percent
13
wow that's it make it 14 please bessie
then we got
corey tidwell five dollars for chap
shout out to gregory i don't care if i
spend my last on sun moon we eating
noodles we're gonna talk about some [ __ ]
boo we're gonna talk we're gonna get to
that
we got our kitchen
for helping with elden ring can't agree
yet the elder room beach breath of the
wild brother while it's still better to
me
i can see why both are great in their
own way
it's just because they like to climb on
anything they see i hear that pause
i told you the the the from software
uh
elitist will come at me if they knew i
helped you with that game
you're selling me out to them he's
watching him out here
continue then we got kendrick star again
two dollars
breath of the wild is overrated too okay
that story graphics all trash
the ring fans is outside smoke for
everybody
then we got the homie k mega member for
two months thank you my brother okay
shout out to the iop panel my brother
dirk griggity good to see you wbz
rapping today
absolutely what's happening hello
and we got shan 786 five pound super
chat
awesome to see my wbg and tts brother on
the iron lords podcast this week salute
to you brothers keep up the good work
and keep talking that she
forgive him what a way
good do you love your brother love you
and you got the wise old gamer member
for 20 months thank you sir
love getting abused over and over again
in elven ring if i had known that i had
that i only had to pay 60 dollars for
all this pleasure i would have paid all
i did for my engagement and wedding ring
i knew it you knew it was covered that's
wise right that's why
you knew it was coming
new is coming
mm-hmm and we have heart city once again
five dollars super chat dr pony is
available to make sure playstation 5's
future is protected patience be damned
oh yeah
yeah i said i know what he did yeah that
was crazy console passion is more
important xbox don't like facts oh my
god here we go
man let's just move on i knew that was
crazy yeah
okay hold on we got a couple of more
that came with
a second
oh god i want to point out that that
poll is overwhelmingly voting for call
anything no nobody
nothing
on my timeline
we got hyper fan gaming two dollar super
chat ray tracing
hey hey man that's my wbg brother he
don't want to start a whole great face
shout out to dave man
then we got lord metro remember for six
months no doubt thank you sir proud
subscriber of this great community and
lord salute to the dirt as well king
tossed trashworth sword to the bushes
when he started eldon ring
oh this guy rashford sword
savage you know what you got to stop
[Music]
that we got flame two dollars super chat
all all by the breath of the wild to the
goat triangle strategy
i think it is an isn't that all bowed to
the goat
not breath for the wild let it go
when they broke into your car and they
gave you kidney stones
they broke in and gave them kidneys
they messed with the important part of
it
[Laughter]
[Music]
big up to the lords adding dirt lord tts
no doubt sir what's up what's up pistol
[ __ ] no doubt that we got tony bryant
10 super chat cog don't let them talk
you into playing light souls fastest
refund ever glad to see dirk crickety
here him and king about to go wild my
man tony bryant feed the wolves tony
feed the wolves i see you
that's right
all right then we have
gaming forte five dollar super chat
anyone say anyone that says zelda's
trash don't know what a great game is oh
come in and come up with somebody
plus [ __ ] went outside the clan to get
that premium experience actually please
hold on let me finish this hey king boo
boo hey
hey guys listen man to be fair i never
said zelda was trash i said it's a good
game just not a good zelda game
before fix your face you went outside
the clan yesterday i saw you when you
were on your ball you did your vlog too
bro and i seen you
[Laughter]
there we have gerald mack member for 18
months all ahead of the iop salute the
lawyers for giving up and uh up and
coming content creators a platform to
grow salute dirt credit
thank you
no doubt
and we got pragmatic eagle five dollar
super chat missed the show last week the
anticipation for this week's show was
through the roof this is the best show
around need to get y'all the netflix
deal yeah that'd be nice
i'll take peacock
yeah or whatever whatever anyways anyone
that got back
exactly we got to be there we got to pay
the bills so we got to take care of some
advanced things right now oh man this is
incredible
that cognito
net here to talk to you about advanced g
your boy has partnered with advanced gg
one thing about me i know i promote a
healthy lifestyle about gamers getting
to the gym gamers doing stuff earning
the right to game i've always been on
that type of thing and i'm very
particular with what i put in my body so
shout out to fursy boxes my last word
co-host you know what i'm saying and of
course khakis hd he's another one you
know i'm a very particular they've been
kind of repping the product for a while
i've been taking it for about over about
a year and i have to admit product is
absolutely fantastic you know when it
comes to those long gaming sessions your
boy probably rocking that focus you know
what i'm saying doing them yeah i wonder
how [ __ ] doing them six hour raids he
probably took some focus before him and
then obviously you know with the gym you
know your boy has to get in there i have
to earn the right to game in order to do
that i usually rock that energy shout
out to that birthday cake absolutely
delicious but um i've been rocking with
the party for a while you know i'm fully
transparent shout out to the entire team
they've been a pleasure to work with and
um
run yourself right now
to advancedgg.com
put in code iron lord 30 on the checkout
that's advanced gg.com ironlord30
and get yourself some advanced gg try to
product out it's absolutely delicious
been rocking for about a year and it's
again full transparency on the label you
get a lot of the information straight up
no gimmicks look if he volunteers like
it and that man don't put condiments on
his fool you know he worried about what
he put in this body so you know i did my
research
all jokes aside man shout out to the ncg
again iron lord 30 your boy the lords
have partnered up check it out support
healthy health is wealth support a
healthy lifestyle go do that thing
so now that you don't mosey on down over
to the website go check it out whether
you're gonna get that focus for the
gaming session that energy a little perk
for the gym we're gonna get some swag
some merch maybe an ice shaker go run on
over there check out the products man
again really cool products they don't
hide behind any type of proprietary
blend bra nonsense it's all transparent
as far as the ingredients the label
green tea caffeine
kind of a healthy form of natural
caffeine none of that crash none of that
stuff so yeah again go check it out you
run in there you add it to your cart use
that referral link that we got in the
description and then you make sure on
the checkout you're putting in
iron lord again iron lord on the
checkout get yourself a nice discount
when you're checking out advanced gg and
like i said try the product for yourself
see what you think about it the lords we
love it and we are powered by vsg to
check that thing out
all right we back we back salute
solution with ncg powered by the lords
right now you know get your boy sipping
on that sour right now i'm sipping on
that sour that watermelon this is crazy
right now you know what i mean some of
that you know because right now i'm
playing elder ring i need that focus
yeah you gotta listen you need you need
something that's for sure
i don't need you over
let me here the bills damn it let me
finish pay the bills um listen man vance
you see salute yo go up to the website
veggies.com iron lord story today's the
last day iron lords 30 get yourself some
money this is the last day for the 30
for the 30
after today you know if you use coal
iron lord you'll still get your discount
but it'll be the temperature
yeah get that 30
you know what i'm saying i was through
the weekend so go check that out salute
to everybody advanced gg again focus
like i said you're doing your launch
gaming doing your elder ring you're
doing your destiny raids you need that
extra kick and their energy like i said
a little pre almost like a little
pre-workout and it says it's no better
lean of that stuff to make you jingle
and all that and it don't make you go to
bed because i used to take c4 that just
made me go to the bathroom i use the
product so i'm telling y'all right now
he's just talking about it it's official
it's official salute to them i am done
now paying the bills and let's add it
but today is the last day for the thirty
percent yes go to advanced gg.com
the chat you know i'm foreign here hello
all right check this out dude's doing
that then kaga's gonna play this elder
ring oh here we go
oh that's what we do with that
i gotta use focus i gotta use focus for
the elder ring
if you buy something off the code man
tag call tag the iop and put it on
twitter what's your bar you know put put
on there
yeah because if they you know what i
can't tell if they bought it so it's
like
if we get five of those things purchased
and king gets his little five things
they'll co-opt for you said my little
five things
[Music]
[Music]
first thing we're going to give away is
we're going to give a general code that
i'm going to give away to to the members
of the the crew so right now if you want
to be available for those two
later on for i think they're 40 codes
yeah 40.
so so if you want to be available for
those member giveaways later on in the
podcast you're going to have to become a
member but we're going to give one away
to the general realm but there is a
caveat you got to have a twitter because
you got it oh yeah the message
uh so this is how we're gonna do it's
gonna be trivia related yes so i got a
trivia question
where was the original xbox announced at
what event was the original xbox
announcement
who got that
um good question good question see what
the xbox dudes is in there for real
real i already knew that
mm-hmm
oh oh oh oh they got some answers in
there
they got some answers in there
[Laughter]
okay that's not what the internet says
oh i see one that got it i see when they
got it yeah i see what i got mm-hmm i
see one it's [ __ ] j
that's what it says on uh the internet
man if the internet's wrong i can't help
that maybe they changed the name maybe
it was named maybe it was yeah back in
the day probably was nancy that's though
back up yeah yeah yeah cause i think
yeah back to this place so give it to
the first one
yeah uh we'll give it to
i saw when he put it it was a ces show
okay
man i'm going to butcher your name
you guys know how this goes
uh
deviantsu
batch
let's obviously
no no yeah
you make
you name yourself that you get butchered
by me
that's how well done what happened
he said davious match i think it's
probably like
a demon
it was officially unveiled to the public
in 2000
ces 2000. yeah
okay i thought it was now it was i don't
i don't remember if the public knew
about it but it was like to to devs it
was earlier and it was kind of official
it was like it was a video
i don't know if we had access i don't
remember to be honest the internet says
uh gdc 2000. it was at the gdc but the
ces was the unveiling gdc they gave the
developers a heads up on what they was
doing and trying to get the development
kits to it and ces show was the complete
unveiling okay
we will give it to the ces because i i
would expect it like an official review
that's one
okay all right so you got the person you
got the name yeah i i butchered your
name but uh you're gonna have to message
me on twitter uh unfortunately uh
because people like to harass me over
dumb stuff but you're gonna have to
tweet me first
and then i will and if you follow me
which you probably do
um just hit me in the dm like it's me
mario no doubt
i'll screenshot it dad no doubt make
sure make sure you hit about uh so we go
with that all solving
we got to get moving
we have uh
eight dollar super chat steam deck just
got an update for a stable 15 frames per
second sounds like it sounds like the
perfect platform from a breath of the
wild to an elderly game
that's
crazy i told you guys that that was
going to be over
what else
then we have oh lord roughness five
power super chat shout out to my iron
lords and what up to my god dirt
question to y'all when is when is
horizon forbidden western gran turismo
coming out hashtag xbox sort of win wow
yeah we're good all right cool just real
quick before we move the dirt i'm sorry
did you guys get to watch the batman no
no
no no wow i was supposed to watch about
that sorry i was supposed to go this
weekend but um we have a new member of
our family
and you know uh shout out to uh my step
kid giving birth to a bigfoot baby
we're good all right let's get to it man
so patiently wait now that we've gotten
all the business and super chat slander
we got
just before we start that keep in mind
like i will be giving more of those
codes away to the members so yes you
know definitely join the realm if you
guys want to be qualified to get into
that get that gg yo i'm telling you slip
so anyway now we got the laws of play
and all that good stuff we got to focus
back on lord dirk griggity his video
game system history his journey to
youtube and of course creating that
channel and we bleed green xbox podcast
so lord great let's start from the very
beginning was some of the first video
game systems you had and what got you
into gaming
well i'm 45 years old so the first
console i vividly remember
uh the actual pong system you know i was
a little kid
yes my sister is seven years older than
me she's my only sibling
we had the physical palm system with the
two knives on it i don't know if you
guys remember
i was never you know surprisingly i was
never a huge nintendo kid
growing up everybody in my hood had an
nes but i chose sega
time out time time on time we we we
speed balling right now we in our era
you already got the pong your sister's
seven years older than you said right
and she got that pong system for you
right so you went right
to atari of course that's all right
right
right with any coleco vision in the
house we didn't get a collegial vision
though we had atari then we went you
know straight to the sega massachusetts
[Laughter]
he doesn't like your history
the master system so what were you a hue
car dude or was you a cartridge guy
i was a cartridge guy i don't i didn't
have any other little cards okay okay
any of those that was all cartridges man
uh you know that was
that was my thing right there uh nes was
fired but everybody had one you know so
i was able to play double dribble my
friend house
super mario
2 you know down the street so it was
just i wanted a sega right i mean i was
that different kid everybody loved
michael jordan i'm gonna love clyde
dressing because i don't want to be like
everybody else you was like me
going to block about that back in the
day i was hating in the beginning wait
wait wait wait wait wait i was just
going
i was in my disbelief phase i was like
he can't be that girl he can't be
better than him i i was riding with the
pistons i was like the pitchers competed
the thing is as a kid you know i'm from
detroit so okay you know you know the
bad boys about it
i respect
at the time you know now i was like yeah
jordan is the greatest now back then
back then back then i was like i like
clyde dresser i know you're in portland
but i like him better so that was me
that clyde the glide clown
was the man
all right you know so
you you playing the the sega master
system mm-hmm
double dragon what's up
yeah man it had two players bro they had
two players
the master system had that duality to it
you know the cards and the cartridges
sleek red and black finish
the little stick in the middle that you
was able to put in the middle of the
controller yeah yes oh yeah yeah yeah
like uh the built-in game got a little
maze oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah hang on i remember that stuff
man
the way you guys talk about these oh the
way these restructured old systems was
built man i feel like you need a degree
i feel like you need a degree just to
operate the little bar in the middle no
i know simple man was simple it was just
our passion man i'm just you know i just
i grew up in the um household you know i
i guess you would call it a party
household because every weekend my
parents they had people over partying so
like i mentioned my sister is seven
years older than me
you know during the summer of course i
you know i'll be outside playing
basketball or something during the win
i'm chilling in my room playing video
games that was my passion i grew up
playing video games so sega was my stuff
and then of course my early teenage
years that genesis came in
here there we go
we was outside at sega kids which is
yeah we were it was our time to talk or
talk we we've endured enough
because it wasn't a lot of us master
system but the fact that you was a man i
know i know that was hardcore sega
yeah yeah that's hardcore continues you
just bypass the nintendo no hold on hold
on i'ma get there okay okay okay
i respected nintendo right right now
with the super nintendo at first i tried
i was living in the denial oh it's not
me
i'm gonna tell you a couple games
but did
that was way like all the multi-players
better right for the most part yeah yeah
because they had mortal kombat 2. now
part one they had the blood so i didn't
care but part two when they
they had the sound
then i had to go ahead and like street
fighter two also i gotta go ahead and
give him
superior multiple yeah
all right so you were talking about the
end of the run because you know for
people that don't know donkey kong
country came when these are
32-bit
yeah and everybody's moving up to 32-bit
leaving past the 16-bit consoles and you
know the 16-bit consoles was the genesis
and it was the super nintendo super
nintendo had that mode seven and that
stuff did you know genesis already done
did the sega cd and they going up to
saturn and they leaving that world
behind
and the last ditch effort was the donkey
kong country and you know that got a lot
of people in yeah did you see any of the
earlier games that was using mold seven
something that was not in the genesis
that may even piqued your curiosity i
remember that ncaa basketball game that
had like oh yeah
yes
that gave me
yes
yes i forgot about that game that was an
amazing game yeah yeah that was fire
that's what maybe oh so i had to stop
living in denial you know my love for
sega genesis i i i couldn't like check
it
out
nintendo fight so by that time i was 18
had me a little job got me an ass in the
ass you know i had to then after that
was the first console you brought with
your own money with my own money i
wanted to use one from from funko land
games fun cold wow
but then um
i remember
i was a second guy but the second saturn
something was about it wasn't
really
true the devil tell the truth shame the
devil they tried to bully me into that
[Laughter]
32x
[Laughter]
[Music]
he like this sound like engineering
all right okay
okay it was a lot you we we jumped past
the second but we didn't even know that
you had to take a cd
i forgot to mention it until i just
remembered yeah we could you could skip
past
that no no we ain't gonna do that
you know i'm being
i just finally found someone that don't
like to sing cd like i don't like i
never thought it was that great but
never let him go
what was that a christmas box was it a
birthday box
when did
maybe about 200 a week
that was enough for me at the time
all right so uh mods in the chat we got
to get rid of pragmatic ego he's got to
go yeah oh
don't do him like this he disrespects
saturn
he made it a crime yo don't do that
speak you're too pragmatic speak
see i never forget when i brought that
sega cd because i thought i was stepping
into the next generation
yeah i didn't know that i was still here
right
real quick real quick dirk tell addict
what because he don't know what to say
to cd like he he told the concept
what was it to the genesis
it was a add-on pretty much right um
add-on you guys tell me this wasn't
complicated you got to add on
it was hey listen i'm gonna tell you
brother i had the sega cd and the 32x
which was another add-on on top of an
add-on
like it really pissed people off
but i was you know
i bought all of it so so you're playing
a console version of legos
yeah that's what it seemed right yes
that's actually a good analogy
yeah i plugged it in and if you have
sonic and knuckles and you put the other
cartridge on top yeah you had a forest
fire going hey
that was the first dlc brother remember
that yeah
that was they figured out how to get us
dlc by selling us
imagine this right you get a cartridge
and the top flipped back
and you can slide the other top
another card that was dlc man yeah thank
you
for that that's dlc yeah
continue this is a great story so he was
going for sega city
yeah so i you know i enjoyed the full
emotion video games with the real actors
and actresses
that got kind of stale but then the ps1
came out blew me away i became a
playstation guy there right okay
i didn't like the n64 i
unfortunately i never got a chance to
play those wwe games
okay okay you missed out on that part
but the rest is just he was good but
then hey conversa got me back though
with that dreamcast oh yeah they got me
back when i came back home that's when i
came back home yeah i told somebody the
other day that i like blue stinger
i remember that game yeah remember it
was it was the last game yeah it was the
launch game
[Laughter]
so
sega dreamcast had
arguably the best ones launch lineup
ever fire any fire
right so so what did you get from your
launch lineup what games did you get
well i didn't get in that launch to be
honest with you i didn't get in launch
i got but like when i did get my saturn
i got you know 2k bats in the nfl 2k
football basketball i got sonic
adventure soul calibur yes it was
something else i got i can't remember
right now
oh uh
that was anime character like the guy
with the eye closed what's the name of
that game
with the big sword
yeah yeah i didn't get it that launched
the dream dreamcast i got it i got it in
2000. okay so yeah man it was um
great console i loved it yeah love the
console you got a story about that
console yeah we gonna
do that some stories about that you got
a story about a particular game on that
console it's legendary legendary story
addict need to hear this one for the
people that don't know
and let's give them the full telling of
this great story that cog sent to me
that i had to watch that i laughed to
death
hey so
okay i'm gonna tell this story
second dream cause i love the console uh
but it was a game that they was
promoting before the console i believe
even came out shimmu i don't know if you
guys heard oh yeah
i know you guys on the panel have i
couldn't wait for this game game blew me
away right
so
at this time you know i'm i'm a young
cat like 22 23 years old i'm married
got a daughter got a stepson
you know it's my family now but i'm not
making that much money at the time right
i had a dream cast and i wanted this
game so the game comes out
i had sixty dollars in my name brother i
swear maybe seventy dollars in my name
this is this this is the bank account
right down the top
now when i say i had seven dollars we
had seven dollars oh this is the family
money
dirk it's the family money
he took the bank
wife was white my ex-wife was working
but maybe ex-wife
oh yeah this is my ex-wife now
so i um i go to gamestop which was fun
at the time and i knew
dirk just just wait just wait a week
then you like you know i like you know
like the devil on one
shoulder
so the age was saying just wait just
wait another week
the dad was like boy you waiting all
this time for that game you better get
that game
so
the devil
put the kids in the food
yeah brother let me tell you something
so i bought the game
i went home
and i told my ex-wife i said look look
baby
i bought this game schnookums
she was like what okay fine whatever
that's how i was there but
we ain't got no money
i mean i just got paid that day
i paid some bills you know some bills
that we had to pay of course
so this is all the leftover money you
paid the bills to he paid the bills that
would prevent him from playing the game
so the electricity was planned
we had a food in the house
so i'll never i can still see my ex-wife
face to this day
she looked at me like
what yeah are you serious that's when
you spend my last on a video
[Laughter]
so just to clarify at this point you
already invested you had to commit
i had to commit absolutely so
so you know we got into it of course
she uh called my mama oh oh no he called
a pastor brother we had to go to the
mayor's counseling oh
at this time i knew i wasn't
oh yeah she called mom she called pastor
so we meet with the pastor i know i was
wrong by this time
you was wrong the moment you made that i
knew i was wrong from the moment i did
it in the meeting you have to show the
game did you have this
to be fair to you
once the transaction happened even if
you would have turned around and said
give me my money back they would have
gave you half
and you can't because yeah at that day
absolutely man so uh i knew what
happened so so like because of this i
couldn't enjoy the game
because the whole time i was playing i
finished it but the whole time i was
playing it was in the back of my head
you idiot you know you dummy what are
you doing
so
we um we eventually got divorced i'm not
gonna say that was the only reason why
but that started it all
the no food
yeah and i actually um convinced her to
come on my podcast it was about maybe a
few months ago
and tell her side of it and that that
was pretty funny man so oh she came back
yeah
20 years later the fact that you guys
were able to move forward you still have
a relationship that's cool regardless
it's a moment what's your favorite yeah
you know we have a daughter together you
know my daughter's 23 nights
a little brother
she can still hold that grudge when she
got she got to remember that she lost
out the shuttle i mean the reason why i
love it is because i think as gamers if
you're a hardcore gamer
you relate to that because there's that
moment as a gamer where you know you're
being irresponsible absolutely like you
know it and you're like damn
you got this conversation and you're
like yo
you know what i'm saying i have to be a
ramen noodle
hey when the kids can eat noodles
so you remember you had to go to mar
bell right yeah yeah
when you don't have marbella bella
that's turned into bell atlantic and you
had to go inside this building with
these long ass lines right and my mom's
always sending me because i felt that
she was too lazy to get and stand on
them long-ass lines so you know you send
out the kid to do it so before i would
go there i would go to these they had
all these little electronic stores
so i would always go inside the
electronics stores to see what video
games they got next right
donkey kong junior hand-held game with
the red buttons
little johnny i would go in there and i
would see it every time
well this time i had enough is enough
so i think that i think that the phone
bill was like uh a hundred and some
change
i think the game was like 50
bucks she gave me all the money
mistake number one
a 10 to 12 year old a hundred and some
odd dollars and say meet you at the pass
so i went there and again i stopped
i looked
i saw the price and i think it said like
10 off
i said i can't pass the sale up
it's a deal yo so she never looks at the
bills
paid for the game had the console go in
there pay the electric bill with the
phone bill or the rest of the money
go home
before i get home i'm i'm walking my boy
hubert davis we're playing it i will
always put your name out there for what
you did to me oh right so yeah
you want to talk about alpo he's the
original yo
but we playing i'm playing we having a
good time i say yo
you do me a favor when we go upstairs if
my mom's asked tell her it's yours yeah
yeah that's it get the story straight
before the cover-up yeah yeah in my head
my mom's can't beat you but she can beat
me right and shout out to all that if if
you're an acs worker i don't care y'all
wasn't saving me back then
the beatings was real continue get
upstairs right
gave my mom's the bill this day she
looked oh no
then she freaks frisk me like the police
brings it who's is this what's what's
this what's this cause i had to i had to
box and all that
oh this is hugh [ __ ]
where's hubert he in the hallway mm-hmm
she opened the door i don't know what
she had in her eyes that he saw but she
opened the door like is this yours you
would say no it's his he told me
but not like that human not like yeah
you can't rattle
for the family
i heard those angels and those devils as
well and i lost out sir so i empathize
with your story sir oh my god
that was a crazy story dirt continued
yeah so uh you know after the dreamcast
you know the ps2 you know everybody you
know
like let's be honest the ps2 killed the
dreamcast yeah they killed it so i had
to
like you know like dreamcast was dead so
i had to move on to the ps2 ps2 loved it
absolutely loved it now i remember a
friend of mine
telling me about this xbox i said yeah i
heard about that man the original xbox
i'm not microsoft making the console
don't nobody want that
[Music]
this is my attitude i'm a ps2 guy baby
but what happened he convinced me yo
dirk man come over to the crib me and my
boys we playing this game called halo 4
playing splits grounds
all right so i eventually went over
there
like wow that was that was fun man that
was fun yeah so eventually you know
maybe six seven months down the line i
was able to get my own xbox that was it
i became a bot
that day
that's what it happened
and you know the question 360 fire
um you know uh you know and now we're
here so what happened how i found this
community
out after you know in 2013 like people
on my pocket as i talk about this all
the time let's tell here we go dirt with
your old 2013 story 24 we got an addict
that tell us that all the time
[Music]
so what happened um i remember
seeing you know e3 and everything i was
like man xbox kind of messed up a little
bit but i'm still going to ride with
them you know
um so i remember being on youtube
looking for positive xbox stuff and i
really couldn't find much yeah no no
like then i eventually found bgst
found tick podcast kids move and some of
those guys
then i said okay there's guys like me
adults
that's passionate about video games so
when i found the community i was like i
love it and you know the first few years
i was just the guy in the chat you know
like saying yo what's up you know they
mentioned like you guys came on and ran
and deal everybody
but i was just the guy in the chat then
i just one day did a video about the uh
nintendo switch
i just turned on my camera i was driving
in the truck i see you bro you remember
how just and i started talking trash
about the nintendo switch
[Laughter]
so now of course i got mostly down votes
on it but
you don't even care yeah i was like yo
i'll be on to something you're keeping
it real though
so of course i became this xbox this pro
xbox channel because my views was you
know i never uh i got maybe one or two
videos that was over two thousand but it
was you know around 100 or so yeah right
so
i'm doing this pro xbox channel and back
in 2017 2018 brothers i know we're all
xbox fans here but let's be honest it
was kind of difficult being a pro xbox
channel especially in 2017 doing xbox
one era
king just did a retrospective on that he
was yeah man
2018
and like 2018 in particular when
playstation had got a war oh lord oh my
god spiderman and those great games
that's why it's really handled but see
if they say it was very difficult so
with no cracking
i tried to defend that one right there
but it was hard man it was difficult to
defend it
but you know i tried my best you know
even though i wasn't doing consoles like
war stuff back then i still got a lot of
you know hate in my chat you know oh you
xbox you blah blah blah so
over the years i kind of test
developed this you know i'm going to
talk trash
this is the provocation
[Laughter]
that's what kind of happened
[Music]
exactly so i'm gonna reflect this back
at you yeah
so then then also uh fellas i saw you
know i thought i said you know what
these guys there's some great content
out here you know iron lords love you
guys you know rand dealer
all these guys
i can't really be like them you can't be
yourself
kind of be myself you know
i can try to be like them but i just
kind of want to be myself and uh
i know my content is raunchy you know we
swear a lot like especially my boy sean
i try to tell him sean
that day i was on your show
y'all dudes kept that 100 clean it was
it was it was dope it was dope yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah um but you know we have fun so and
people seem to like it
so you know we're just having fun and
over the years
i've grown a little bit you know um i've
grown
so
there's an audience here that's right
there's an audience for everything and i
was the guy that used to love howard
stern back in the day right
and i thought how
everybody wanted him to do his content a
certain way that's true be how everybody
else is that's a good point and he said
you know what i'm gonna do it my way and
they didn't like it but the audience did
yeah so that's kind of how i look at it
as long as people keep on saying dirt i
like what you're doing i know there's
people that's not going to like it but
if those guys
like our content
i'm going to keep on doing it respect
respect i mean at the end of the day
like you know everybody's got a lane and
you know you got to call me we had to
carve our own at one point you know
saying we made our own decision but
again i don't knock anybody for for
doing the content the way they want to
do it and then you put your spin on it
and one thing i got to give you your
your credit is that one thing i like is
you do keep it real when you feel even
though obviously clearly pro xbox we
know where you're riding you know what
i'm saying right but you always keep it
real when then you feel they're not
doing something you know correct or they
you know and you give credit to the
other side also right so the bigger
playstation yeah the thing i wanted i
also want to give you guys because i
like your little spin on it for me perk
my joy is the um the ruby
oh yeah yeah
i love him
you know what it is is
guys from our era that time
we have a correlation with certain
things we see things in a different
light in a certain manner and that's
what i got from when i was on your show
that's the reason why when you hit me
people don't know like i watch
everything i'm in everything i'm peeking
at everything i may not put any comments
or anything there so but i do look so
when you hit me
how fast did i hit you back yeah yeah
that's cool
yeah right i'm there i can't wait let's
go um
and it was no no no stipulations none of
that stuff there because i believe in
the the the the host i believe in the
content of the show i believe in exactly
where you're going with it and actually
i see your vision with it right and i
was like this dude is true to him like
he brings his flavor so i got that from
that and i said that's what separates
everything
you know like you said you saw dealer
you saw coal you see everybody else
doing their thing how they do it and
what i can say about these individuals
is you know like rand and everybody
they have their own particular style
mm-hmm and that's how hip-hop was back
in the day that's how it was yeah he
bought it you got nwa you had charcoal
you had you had different bags everybody
could everybody could win you know i'm
saying and again the same way you know
he reached out to you reached out to me
and i was like yeah brother you know
what i'm saying
i can't and they show wild love
wow salute man
everybody
see you know jay-z don't sound like naz
yeah right right you know like a z don't
sound like nahs right snoop dogg when we
grow up in the diversity that everybody
was flourishing it right what i what i'm
saying i'm saying this to younger
podcasters and younger people getting in
the game right now don't go be iron
lords don't go and try to get what dirk
do do what you do like he said he was
just sitting there and he you felt the
passion in your stomach that then he was
just like man i'll put this video up
cause i'm not feeling this way
i wasn't feeling it
and you got it out there and your
response back to it was that that was
the affirmation to you
that that the 2k that you got the views
you was like what
and that was that that boost to keep you
going to keep you moving because you
know as much success as you had with
that first joint i'm pretty sure like
you said those little hundred views yeah
30 here 40 here
yeah
but i kept on grinding though kept
grinding he kept grinding at the end of
the day like i said it was really cool
shout out to addict to to really put
that out there as far because we want to
get new voices up here we want to you
know what i'm saying and and pay it back
you know in the same way it kind of paid
back on us for a little bit you know
saying we're trying to pay it back so
you know i respected that your name came
up a lot and then also i want to shout
out the podcast man let's talk that uh
weebly green talk about that how did
that start what's going on i had a uh
shout out to my boy mm2k he's a stadium
guy but he had uh you know like he had a
weight loss
yeah
i'll be the best
i got this podcast like you want to be a
member i said yeah sure so eventually
like he just gave it to me like yo you
taking on your channel okay so it was it
was dope man we were having a lot of fun
but what happened um after e3 2019
heath kind of flip-flopped he started
bashing xbox
and something i hated when i would go to
my favorite
x pro xbox podcast and i would hear a
lot of xbox bash all the time not
like criticism is different right
so
my my podcast was started to become that
now why is it becoming this constant
xbox hating on my channel and
the people that was listening are more
pro ed spots because they were
subscribed to my channel so they were
starting to hate it
so i said you know what i need to start
an xbox podcast
so
the idea was in my head because i felt
after 2018 2018 i said xbox is going to
be pretty dope next generation they
bought autumn studios in 2018 i'm like
they're going to be dope next generation
i want to start a pro xbox podcast so i
procrastinated a minute then my boy
devin um like for my uh podcast he said
dirk after like you know what it was
when xbox came out when phil spitzer
came out and said the xbox series x is
going to be 12 teraflops right
it was a monday that day we said let's
start the show tonight yes we called a
couple guys and like we just wanted to
talk trash you know
and we got a pretty decent turnout our
first show unannounced we got like 70 80
live viewers i'm like wow
so we kept on doing that we kept on
talking trash we kind of built
this audience of
trash talking you know what i'm saying
and you know we love it they love it and
here we are man two
108 episodes later we're still here i
mean
how are we going you know absolutely
salute to the t shout out to the team
though shout out to the team oh shout
out to all my boys man my boy sean 786
who who's in the uk
and we go live you know at first we're
going to be a night show at 8 o'clock
right
you know like the time difference is so
big he's five hours ahead we started at
6 30 and it's still late for him but he
sacrifices he comes there and he does
his thing my boy devin
my boy johanzo found him cracking i
don't know if you ever see them in the
chat with my homies oh yeah we've seen
that r b
and um my boy tsunami he's not with the
show at the moment but he's a big part
of the show so yeah man um those are the
homies man and you know we have guests
like you guys we try to get guests on
here like if they're smaller youtubers
bigger youtubers if if we can and we
just have fun yeah listen you have fun
you're grinding you know and i just like
the fact that at least you know where we
come from obviously you from you know
what i'm saying from detroit i know
israel you know what i'm saying from new
york and look at the end of the day
everybody's got to lay and i like
brothers at least putting that energy in
the platform you know what i'm saying
and that part is really cool and then
just in general like i think you got a
unique lane i personally tell you what
[ __ ] like
cog like when you do like you're in the
life you don't say type choice but you
do like the video your video bag is
hilarious and then like he'll have his
daughter on the track
and be like you like this this black
child said are you doing some funny joke
like you don't know the door like your
old daughter and it's just hilarious how
you be incorporating stuff like that but
yeah appreciate it you got a lot of
talent brother and i like to see that
energy continue so keep doing what
you're doing we got to celebrate that
but you know we got to ask the question
we always ask those in the realm
i need more dirk griggity's top five
video games or franchises of all time
all right let's get it um
well uh
sonic is one of my favorites i always
love sonic and sonic 2 in particular oh
man
that's that's that's one of my favorite
childhood games
mortal kombat is a great franchise is up
there for me
they uh love that franchise let's go oh
excuse me
um
three i will say you know what franzia's
i absolutely loved and hope it comes
back one day
prince of
persia i love that franchise great
french i guess though yeah i hope it
comes back one day
now i'm going to tell your friends
because i love god of war i love that
you see christopher
i love that award man i got to be honest
which which god will go for it
i thought 2018 is phenomenal all kick is
out of here like that better than
earlier
um man the first trillion
the initial trilogy man was amazing oh
man the witness yeah he's definitely
leading the way i'm just saying that
i just want to hear from the man's mouth
he definitely leave it with us
oh man
the original trilogy was phenomenal bro
uh 2018
next level next level you can say maybe
i'll put 2018 a little bit above the
original trilogy
tell me what get out of it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he couldn't lead the witness so now he
wants to go
[Laughter]
duck
the last question i think i know
favorite console of all time and why
yeah you're gonna pick from your kids
you go pick
yeah
you know that's that's a tough question
uh
okay i know my top three so i would say
oh man
it would have to be
i want to say this i'm going to say the
ps2 let me say
okay you might not be able to go back to
well 360
360 was almost there yes but the reason
i say the ps2 is a personal let's go
reason um i was going through you know
after i got a divorce
and
all i had was my tv and my ps2 my man
and they carried me from watching movies
to playing video games and uh it carried
me i was living in this career about six
seven months right before i was able to
move out you know and um so
that's like that's the personal reason
why ps2 is one of my favorite consoles
but another you know if you want to yeah
give it let me go let's see
we got to give it up we got to give it
up because dirk i saw you on twitter
and you actually made it you were the
couple bro i think it was jr i called
the people it's a it was an argument
going on i was i was looking at how the
violence in the twin streets was that
day and i was i was nosy i was i was
looking at the block
and um y'all made some good points y'all
was like look the we know the players
two had amazing games we're not going to
take that away but in the beginning of
the console cycle outside of the launch
people don't forget
you made a good point the fact that it
was an affordable
dvd player which dvd hadn't had big
adoption rates
at that time so you know
it was new technology and it was
graphically superior than what was
before right amazing amazing and then
you so it was the de facto
dvd player to get it made no se even if
you weren't a gamer it made no sense to
not get a ps2 because the cheapest dvd
player there you go but it was also one
of the best
even if it looked like an amp i don't
care like you know because it didn't
look like an amp
yeah yeah it did like like a yeah music
yo
hard times and things wasn't right and
i'm getting that get you through
sometimes you know what i'm saying you
can't don't talk about when to win
like when the child support here i was
oh
i need that ps2 every morning
that's real
how did they come up with that ratio
yo dirk is a legendary salute these are
real stories real hardcore gave it true
story i believe
in being transparent now i'm not going
to tell all of my business of course
but i believe it being transparent man
we all human we all have our issues we
all go through things man i'm not going
to sit here and lie
man
i can relate so many people can relate
brother like we've all been through it i
love this [ __ ] booster i think that's
classic i know that feeling but i just
respect they'll say you're a hardcore
gamer you're really about the game at
the end of the day that's what it is
hopefully you can get like a little
cartoon of it made up yeah yeah yeah
i want to see
cartoons of
stuff that i did in my past
my boy um sean 786 made a little skit
of the whole shamu story man it's
absolutely hilarious so you got to get
that
yeah you got to get that to us for real
for real
so we got a lot of show to get to
solve i'm going to get the super chats
queued up or you want to hit the poll
yeah while i do this you got the i think
i'm good on this one and dirk let me
know time wise how we doing if you're
good you're still rocking and rolling
you want to stick around you got
anything you got to do i'm rocking bro
okay cool my man just wanna make sure
he's got it hold on a couple a couple
more jump do the poll yeah all right
i'll do the paul i'll do the poll all
right so last week poll results are in
the people have spoken with the massive
financial and critical success of elder
ring which game releasing in 2022 do you
think has a shot a challenging for game
of the year the winner of the three-way
ilp poll at 57 percent of the vote
was
starfield
so people really thinking starfield
might have a shot at the champ coming in
at second place at 36 of the vote was
the messi lords
stop the fight
2022 game of the year already over eldon
king they already stated so 36 strong
and only
5
of the vote was god of war ragnarok how
disrespectful
wow that was wow i see what's the facts
man can't do reused assets man
you don't get the win with the old stuff
man you did that already god bless
moving on but clearly king has spoken
salute salute that's what we've got
i love god of war and i agree
but you know star feel like i told
people
star field is that unquantifiable
quantity because we don't know we don't
know what it's going to be
what we do know is
it's made for this generation
there ain't no fall back it ain't no you
know old
you know xbox one is in consideration no
you're gonna cloud that you're gonna
cloud that but what we're gonna do we're
gonna play this here and i think they're
learning all the stuff that they talked
about all the stuff that's not in
certain games right now like the
velocity architecture and
stuff like that all that stuff will get
into this game and i expect it to be
beautiful i expect it and if it's not
y'all gonna get roasted i'm done with
you anyway so i'm sorry i got added
i do think that starfield could easily
win it it just
it just depends on what condition
starfill comes out when it comes out and
how much are they trying to like
how much they try to change from their
formula
because sometimes when you when you try
to do drastic change you end up losing
what made your game what made you what
made you great yeah and you don't
attract the people that you think
they're go you're gonna attract in the
first place
absolute salute solve are we ready with
them super chat sir
yes sir
we got cucumber once again five pounds
i had to try to say it as normally as
possible
uh cucumber pop powder super chat tts
dirt pressed up to those noodles
noodles
ramen
[Laughter]
ramen
exactly there we go
we got the homie fonzarelli gave me i
just just rapped to him a little bit
yesterday five dollars to be chat i'm
still out for the count but i'll be back
in the community more as soon as i can
kick this post-op pneumonia great to
hear you guys and see saab back great to
see you on the mend my brother
definitely yeah well soon you will find
it well
then we got fandom cracking five dollars
super chat my boy dirt in the realm
don't tell that sun moon story
too late fandom too
what's up joey how you doing brother
and we have boondi five dollar super
chat wah gwan everyone have to listen
tomorrow to keep up with the good work
enough respect to dirt griggity
[Laughter]
then we got east texas alex two dollars
super chat uh they said nothing thank
you my brother then we got tony bryant
ten dollars to be chat my wife just
walked in and said king david looks like
sleepy brown from outcast
that stuff hey that's not bad though we
gotta do a little bit
it ain't going to be easy against
eldering i never said it was if you
remember correctly i said elder ring got
gaming vr already yeah he was on i'm not
going to
to like underestimate the kind of studio
that bethesda software is yeah
i mean they they literally probably if
you look at studios they probably have
the most game of the years out of
everyone mm-hmm
and this is the new ip yeah the first
thing is god that's god howard the a
team we can't be disrespectful here we
go 18 right yeah with the money of
microsoft that is true
and then we have the ash and luca
what's good this is my bro shout out to
the dirt hashtag team s box no doubt
luca
luca man
then we got post up two dollar super
chat shout out to the dirt what a great
dude in person
pulse is my homie yeah salute the post
man host is the homie man good dude
man that's a lot of basketball posting
people up what's up
that's the shot right there maybe that's
the shot salute yeah we got abigail 72
five dollar super chat peace and love to
the lords and rest in peace to calalle
from tick podcast i remember when he was
a guest on the show that's what got me
the sub to you guys down there all right
peter cow no doubt then we have gamer by
choice 10 super chat the iron lords and
dirt one of the best ways to enjoy a
sunday great show king and dirt is like
the houston rockets twin towers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
webcam things that that's a media hidden
yeah yeah that's a media high for the
channel yeah don't talk salute fans
though for getting on it early but yeah
if you see then they'll be they'll be
back in 300 seconds yeah yeah if you see
them for the night.coms in here
make
hit
[Laughter]
came out in 1998 and will be 25 next
year do you agree that phil spencer phil
spender needs to get gabe to make a
remastered port with blue shift and ops
for a single player stories for xbox
series console that would be amazing
i think phil should have listened to
attic i really i really do because i
think attic was on to something i don't
care how much it costs to get elder ring
and game pass i think that right there
would have been that's out of the huge
yeah i mean that'll be huge
especially if you could have got them
before because i i don't think from
software they knew they had something i
don't think they expected it to go this
yeah i think from from is kind of more
now after this feels more mainstream now
the bag has to be bigger if you want
yeah yeah man
yesterday's price ain't today
[Laughter]
a year ago and worked out some kind of
deal a year ago yeah like before like
they would have literally
potentially game of the year already in
game pass they would have been huge for
them it would have been it would be huge
for sure
you could never know stuff like that
though no you can't yeah
you know
then we have paulie baba two dollars
thank you for the two dollars thank you
brother oh hi
no hashtag noodles you put it
noodles
everybody
assassin's creed division far cry are
the three pillars of open world ubisoft
is god's here you'll be stopped out here
like pizza everybody takes a bite i i
ubisoft out there and they were one of
the first especially you know 360 that
original assassin's creed making
but
they they they've had they've had a
little bit too much of their own
kool-aid it's enough
the thing is like i do agree that like
my issue with ubisoft was they started
like
foundation jumping like making
everything like
assassin's creed template or watch dogs
like i feel like you can have all the
assassins creeds feel this similar but
when you start making watchdogs feel
like assassin's creed you start making
every frame as you own phil about
another game then that's why i generally
have the issue with like i don't
understand where this this ubisoft hate
came from like i understand that they're
they're a copy and paste type of
developer and publisher but there's a
reason they do that they're making
millions well it's successful people are
buying it for sure no but you know what
gets me though
when you look at i i still like i said i
i try to love horizon i try to love it
in the same way i love assassin's creed
and i don't because it's something about
those worlds i don't care you can say
they copy paste whatever you could say
but when you look at the when you look
at what they try to do historically with
these settings in assassin's creed a lot
of work goes into those games
you can talk blow you can talk all you
want and that's
fair with those games yeah i mean the
combative scene is one of the best open
world games i've ever played
which one added
odyssey assassin's creed oh my god i
didn't really like van gaal a whole lot
but i love both of them odyssey was just
honestly it was better though yeah
honestly
uh valhalla knew uh
oh yeah they got some time remember
yeah i mean origins set it off for me
because i have fell off of assassin's
creed yeah and being you know the
egyptian stuff that and then
sliding down the pyramid yeah but they
took it to the next level with odyssey
and i gotta con tribute that to attic
again because attic was talking about
assad was talking about it and then you
know addict does that thing again when
you got to see it and then you just like
fomo so i gotta really start watching
this channel
continue absolutely oh by the way
soon early boring day delilah hd i see
you in the chat
already locked in we got the day locked
splendiferous
two dollar super chat boy it seems like
the lord's wide open today run wow
i don't know i don't know about that why
don't we hold on to that early part
where i was talking about elder ring and
with the women oh
what do you mean
and we got smitty smith ten dollar super
chat salute to the lord dirk griggity
and chatting
the book of acts yeah
somebody smith the homie man
we get a book made up with the ex
then we got he's on a mind of its own
yeah he had no choice but he had no
choice but he's been there you know i
got dragon summonses too how about that
you know me you know what
time
on the comparison
there we go
once again jordan around welcome the
lord bronze ministries put the crest in
the chat for smitty
we got
joe tour 2 joe tour
your tour 2 5 super chat found you on
2021 and been hooked since shout out to
the old school hardcore gamers watching
y'all vibe with dirt acg and other og's
gets the knee thank you
thank you
king king was i was on acg last week
king was on this week
fantastic it's so much fun yeah
acg if y'all have never watched the
intro to his show please don't oh it's
hilarious
i i've never been the kind of person
where i look at something and i'm like i
want that you know what i'm saying like
yeah can i look at that yeah i'm like we
need something yeah that's it's
hilarious
what else we got
we got hollywood rules five dollar super
chat another great ilp sunday with the
video game for horsemen congrats dirk
you guys are replacing my football
sunday splendidly hit that like button
that's powerful that man gave up his
football that's real ball in general
my jet's been gone
now jess actually won the playoff game
before
but listen your man went off to go get
his ring yeah you can see that's proof
right there
in the last 12 years they couldn't win
the playoff game
i was a low-key i was a low-key lions
fan just for barriers for barry saying
this yeah
i had to walk away yeah i always get the
players i like him and megan
all right that's the curse but listen
had mark sanchez left the jets and
winning winning ring i would have i
would have set everything on fire
let's set this football talk on fire
we got we got hard to find remember for
11 months thank you sir i've
unfortunately learned way more about
king's kinks over these 11 months salute
to my guys peace
and love fellas how do you think that's
what i'm into method not
move it up talk about what y'all into
uh-huh
then we got jd gamer five dollars super
chat i originally found the lords
through cal-el and tick network so shout
out to him and he had me too yeah we had
to give we had to give kyle's flowers
earlier absolutely
and we got
dragon heart yobe tv 20 super chat
hashtag peace love life same to you my
brother to the legends dirt what up
gents please stay safe keep up on your
health i'm proud of y'all throw the
crust up for yourselves y'all are paving
a path of greatness we all are carving
out greatness thank you thank you
always
always with a message of positivity i
appreciate that
then we got kushik
okay two pounds super chat
heisenberg voice at attic say my name
you got to say it kind of saying like
heisenberg said
okay a little breaking bad heisenberg we
all caught up hey my name yeah we're
covered all right so let's get you know
who i am no i don't
look yo we got to get into these topics
so there's a big one that kind of came
through you even see microsoft kind of
get behind it itself with their tweets
on the xbox account microsoft was
metacritic's highest rated publisher in
2021 with the largest average score ever
it comes out
but
metacritic has revealed that microsoft
is the winner of the 12th annual game
publisher ranking countdown so there
were 10 products published by xbox game
studios reviewed in 2021 five of those
games released over various formats and
the average metacritic score was 87.4 of
kings laughing of these titles 100 were
rated good and three of them already
great scoring over 90. we had forza
horizon 5 psychonauts 2 and xbox series
x version of microsoft flight simulator
so according to metacritic this marks
the first time a publisher has ever
averaged over 85 metacritic school in a
year since its annual ranking started 12
years ago so this is the big topic
that's kind of been going on shout out
to xbox and
shout out to them actually i've seen a
lot of people retweeting it from the
executive level you know as far as
what's going on here so let's get into
it dirt man you are up what are you
thinking about this news was it
surprised you how do you feel microsoft
is the number one rated publisher 2021
i think it's absolutely incredible um if
you really think about how you know
i don't i hate going back to the last
generation but you know how some games
last generation was in the 60s and xbox
had the stigma of not having quality
first party games with the exception of
forza horizon and maybe a gears
franchise big mac launcher
is what they used to call it
for the halo gears continue
that's it so to see that not only did
they win the
metacritic publisher of the year for
2021 they actually broke a record for
them that's incredible man
i mean to have an average of 87. yeah i
know listen i know metacritic is a is
people's opinions and all that stuff but
at the end of the day that's what
everybody goes by you know whether it's
for bragging rights trash talking or
whatever
so to see what xbox is doing man i
i love it
i'm absolutely amazed by and i was
slightly surprised by it let's be honest
yeah
and i think that also goes to show that
um this is not the same on xbox that
everybody's used to this is a different
xbox that
that's going to drop quality content
when you have so much in development
simultaneously uh there's going to be
time right because i always say the
like besides budget time is
definitely the most important thing for
teams and they're going to have time so
i believe they will continue to make
more quality product in the future man
so yeah so kudos to them and i'm really
happy that they
did this no doubt no doubt what addict
i'm very curious about your thoughts i
don't get to think we got a chance to
talk about it so um yeah man what do you
think metacritic highest rated publisher
microsoft sure
this is like i've said from the start
man like microsoft didn't go out and buy
studios that doesn't know how to make
games but for the most part like
double fine like you look at their
studios and what they've typically
reviewed the majority of them are in the
80 plus the majority of them are and you
know they got bethesda
software which literally like i said
earlier
arguably has the most game of the year
out there then you got something like
obsidian which really hasn't made above
an 87 below in 87 forever like the
majority of their games is is around the
85 up like the majority of them are like
you got south park stick of truth you
got the outer world like you got a lot
of quality there like you know obviously
there are studios that that they do need
to prove themselves i will say under the
labs need to prove themselves compulsion
games need to prove themselves but as
far as besides these studios like
i don't understand people really feel
like just because microsoft bought them
it's like they're just going to tank in
quality like completely taken but we
have had people on this podcast such as
obsidian that said the only thing that's
changed he says our quality is going to
change it's going to go higher because
they are giving them the tools the
finances and like you know like he said
time a lot of publishers when you go out
with these publishers it's like a one
and done kind of publishing deal they
want their results they're not going to
care about a studio that they're
probably only going to make one game
with so when you give these people the
opportunity and the time and the
and the resources to make a game the
quality is going to go up uh i'm pretty
sure starfield probably was going to
come out last year but microsoft has the
studio they're like look we got plenty
of stuff this year
next year
go ahead make sure that your game
functions correctly because we all know
that bethesda used to be one of those
studios that got the past when it comes
to broken games but i don't think
they're going to get that kind of that
kind of slack this time they gotta they
got to prove themselves before they get
that title back
so
you look at that you you look at all
these developers all the it's just
obviously you're going to have good
resulting games and we saw it last year
double fine with psychonauts an amazing
game a lot of people considered it a
game of the year contender it's like it
was amazing whatever whatever they make
next it's gonna be on you know maybe not
necessarily a bigger scale because i
don't feel like double fine wants to
make huge games but it's going to be a
better skill in terms of quality like
they're going to have better animations
they're going to have better forms of
cut scenes hopefully you know and we saw
it from a standpoint on wasteland 3. we
saw it from psychonauts where microsoft
was like look
we we need you to be the best you can
what do you need
waistline was like we need to delay we
would pre appreciate to put other stuff
that we had to cut from the game yeah
into our game
double fight with psychonauts
no bosses and psychonauts before
microsoft's like take the time you need
put the game the way you want the game
to be and because microsoft it's hard
you know there's a realm where microsoft
didn't give them that that those extra
time
and they didn't make a game they made
they made a game with no bosses and if
you look at it a lot of the bosses is
the reason psychonauts scored so well
absolutely that would not have been in
the game if it wasn't for microsoft good
point good point facts facts attic yeah
been fantastic boys lord solve what's
that man what are we thinking about this
uh metacritic situation where yet
i mean i think it's
for it to be the first time in the
12-year history of sort of metacritics
you know aggregating these things and
for it to be the first time that any
publisher gets over like an 85 average
that says a lot that says a lot and
marcus a lot of things fell into place
for microsoft last year a lot of things
that were delayed
out of earlier years you know kind of
found their place in 2021 and we had to
figure out you know how to how to put
all that stuff in place
around things like forza and halo and
you know all those those games as well
you know seeing some kind of delays
it was kind of like the perfect storm
and to have that many quality games re
like drop in succession when you think
about it the more games you put out
the harder it is to keep that average up
right like i was looking at the list
nintendo didn't make the top 10 and they
released 18. wow
wow that's a hard thing to do
to publish that many games and to keep
that average up there but even though
like you know they're still kind of in
the 80s though but it's really hard to
get over that 85 hump so for them to
release 10 products and to have it you
know up there over 85 is insane and i
think
the game they had saw was
age of empire and that was still an 83
or something like that
that's
and that's an amazing game so it is that
thing where i just think
the the argument that was being made
about the quality about x of xbox games
yourself yeah the i've given today just
first they have no games and then they
can't put out quality games
um i think that's out the window now i
think they understand uh you know
cyberpunk wasn't that long ago but that
cyberpunk moment really lit a fire under
everybody about yeah
no one no one is impervious to this yes
good point good point you have to put
out a quality product
you know
you got to really
you know we get props to phil spencer a
lot on here but
if you look at it he has took so many
bad stigmas from the microsoft brand he
took the power narrative away
for a minute he took the quote-unquote
69 metacritical way now
it's kind of it's kind of insane and i
don't know that this year is going to be
the same because it's just going to be
less releases right but i i remember
i've been hearing
luke
it's just it's just a matter of there
will be less
you know
[Laughter]
there will be less releases this year if
they do achieve that number again it'll
be less impressive just because it's
less games right
but next year's looking kind of wow like
once again 2023 looking wow i know
maddie's been saying this for the
longest time and it's true 2023 the way
things are stacking up feels like a year
where this is going to be they they're
gonna hit that cadence of every three
months
what about 2022
222 still is there but
i don't hear no talking oh hey don't
talk about 2022 what's up if you look at
it from from this year like i gotta deal
with dinner
i mean how many times does this dude
have to do this we gonna give you your
balls hold on
you getting your balls you about to get
your legs
what is the problem with me saying this
you can't say that you can't be
what they did last time was incredible
oh okay it's incredible so they pop
champagnes already they pop champagne
they're chilling
we cutting off something every month we
cut off attic
in terms of the games this year
you know obviously we don't know
everything but it's just like it is
light like we can't say it's not like
not lighter what is it
i will say next
though it is going to be crazy like i
i'm pretty sure a vowel is probably
coming out next year we're probably
going to get uh some kind of retake on
forza in in some way it's just like hail
blade
hell i don't know if hellblade would
come out next year maybe i i don't know
that that's
we don't know about those games for this
year but we don't know yeah if we you
know
here we go
[Laughter]
like i'm actually like i know we say
this a lot but i'm really excited this
year for whatever their e3 equivalent
yeah i do want to see
a few months away
this is one of those times where it's
like
the amount of stuff that's about to to
be out of the oven
i'm i'm expecting a lot of gameplay like
i am personally and i'll be disappointed
if i don't see a decent amount of games
i agree with you out there yeah they're
wild and they're walling in the chat
mods what's up don't don't don't don't
acknowledge it because then they're just
going to keep coming in here more and
more like
just get rid of them we're not going all
right no doubt all right so we good
we're good um solved
yes we're good apparently
you've been not even removed from the
panel
okay so uh metacritic man highest rated
publisher 2021
microsoft has the type oh we got shades
out what are we doing what's going on
okay
[Music]
it's only just begun
[Laughter]
you dudes haven't been listening when
i've been talking man
12 years and who came through if you
were to bet your life you'd be dead
because you just said playstation gonna
do it before these dudes did and then
what you did you cracked your head
because they on one baby who did that
for you phil dominus maximus aurelius
spencer what he's done
he keeps taking away your narratives
first it was power
oh
then it was price oh my god he's in the
building
now it's games what was it was i was
y'all only you can't get past 69. shut
up
shut up
shut up tell him that's right king
oh god you are feeling the this is you
did this to yourselves
like your words have aged poorly it has
aged disgustingly what's happening
y'all did not think they would be
developer
of the
how crazy is that
it smells delicious
but kings they're gonna say oh now you
care about better critics school
before
i knew they was dope before y'all even
had to put a number on it
so y'all dudes out here capping for that
metacritic
you came up short buddy
you came up short but guess who
oh my didn't
so what you did was you used something
that you thought that they could not
achieve and they achieved it in your
face now you got dudes are sitting here
right you got dudes that's trying to be
a little lukewarm and trying to tell you
oh temper your expectations to hell with
that
we want this year too
and i don't care if we launch four games
there's gonna be four games that's very
highly rated all right horizon's outside
horizon bruh nah i don't want to hit at
the end of the year
what i'm saying is maybe they didn't
have nothing right now yes that is very
quick
what they did was they put up a game
that more people probably completed
and more people don't find boring
you understand what i'm saying do we get
where i'm at with it all right so they
looked at your horizon and said we
raised you guardians and you know what
you said you know why they could say
that because they they're metacritics
but that is not a microsoft published
character yeah
because
you know what it is it's so sad it's so
sad that y'all have been beaten so bad
that y'all can't be why are we telling
the truth we've been beaten into
submission you how dare us mentioned at
the top of 2022 doesn't have much
you know what it is y'all feel of your
smile something bad
man
you gotta say we got that jet set lying
to them
this is good time man
for the metacritic people
praise that
i don't care if you on the other team
you got to respect what metacritic said
nobody in their 12-year history nobody
in a 12-year history that's fascinating
that's crazy
you're not taking
so i don't care about metacritic but
what i do care about is dope games right
yeah so
you know what happens when you put out a
dope game metacritic recognizes it
i'm done because i got something else
for you guys i like metacritic and our
fans are the other side of the street
see this is not an xbox podcast
but i'm an xbox dude so when i get xbox
news i'm gonna bring it straight
and clearly you have to remind us salute
to you
i got you a question
yes hey king who started that metacritic
back and forth
generation
oh it was it was it was the dudes that
was talking to 1080p uh 900p stuff and
they don't know that no more
you know we have the same memory brother
you know that rendering dudes were
saying it was a checkerboard dude
it was the dudes with the tcl television
dudes with the tv on top of the dresser
and you bump it and hit the floor
you know i would not i wasn't quite sure
but i'm glad you just helped me remember
thank you brother oh yeah you're welcome
sir anytime you need a recollection
these two together it's gonna be a
problem with this topic
i can already see this brother you know
what it is i think it's still i think
it's a 13 percent of dudes that finish
that game
oh my god
wow
really really yeah i love you still
sleeping right now you know what they
did they woke up to elder ring
i gotta play something that's
despite playstation's um strong top of
2021 i thought they started up strong i
gave it though i i have to give it that
like microsoft i told people that that
that was their year they had the year it
was a phenomenon
listen man you know psychonauts you're
ridiculous age of vampires fly sim you
know what i'm saying and then you end
with some game of the year candidates
and we know how i feel about forza
horizon 5. you know i'm saying like it
was absolutely halo infinite to end the
year
massive one-two punch and look you know
we got to give it up you know at the end
of the day i'll be honest i've like i
didn't
realize like highest score ever like
that definitely did surprise me that is
that's crazy
and for the record i am the guy that do
not really care about better click like
that for the questions
for sure yes please no no no no no no
here we go i just want to ask a question
because this is his part and i do
apologize for joining
clearly that's a little bit messy but
yes the question is microsoft started
off slow last year too right
um that's a good point that's good
right because you know um sony you know
always had the first half of the year
right that's a good point nobody
remembers what they did in the first
quarter it all boils down to what kevin
durant does in the rest of the game and
when they walk home with their w no
doubt at all
all i've said is with the start of the
year that sony's having in 2022 right
and from what we know all we know is red
fall
and starfield as of right now not saying
that nothing's coming right so again the
early lead you got to give it to them
right now like you they've got horizon
out what was over there sifu hour oh and
definitely
all i'm saying is we got to see because
yes
i can't really say much about that
because he ain't really entirely wrong
about that gt no he ain't wrong about
that he didn't want that but we got it
we can't front like horizon we know
elder rings you know definitely did what
elder ring did and we get that but look
it's gonna be a phenomenal look i told
people i gave i said yo xbox did that
last year like for sure and it was i was
like wow this is impressive to see so
saluted absolutely and what was
interested in veto dirk was like you see
microsoft tweeting like yeah like when i
was talking like to me when you see xbox
execs tweeting about this news yeah well
what that reminds you of uh
that reminds you of when um uh holyfield
pushed mike tyson yeah up against the
war like what now like what now you're
like like this is like
bullying and now it's like no i got you
down like it's one of them type moves
i respect it
and i told people to dirt's point like
i've said before and shout out to
bradford's in the chat as you know i've
said this to you we had this
conversation
every generation is a clean slate
absolutely every generation is a
cleanest way and i told people
regardless to what we know sony's track
record we know the history but microsoft
is coming and these are the type of
things people were excited about the
investment in game studios the
investment in games and early we're
starting to see it pay off and we you
know they even got the the major stuff
coming like you know like atticus was
talking about we got about you got you
know
hellblade is it's a lot of stuff dark
perfect that's a lot for freestyle that
wasn't even gonna beat
i don't know if you guys have been i
don't know if you guys
saw it but did you see that
microsoft
beat
playstation and worldwide last month
yeah the mpd numbers yeah yeah yeah
we're doing that like you're right there
you that just it's a new generation just
that just that new generation yeah
microsoft beat them worldwide yeah that
was a little man yeah [ __ ] like you said
brother yeah he's definitely clean
those tcl television dudes tcl tell them
move the world so little man is out here
coupled with every tcl
i will say this about little man i got
that x green little man is outside
little babies outside i ain't going for
it but get it dirty finish your point no
no i was saying brilliantly right it's a
clean slate you never know
what's going to happen in the brand new
generation if you would have told me the
ps2 155 million cops sold
going into the ps3 you know they were
kind of arrogant yo we're going to try
600 for this y'all gonna like
and people said no we're not gonna buy
it and they didn't buy it so that goes
to show you even with the xbox one they
made some bad decisions and people say
yo we love the 360. but i'm going to go
ahead and get a ps4 i knew people
personally in my life
die hard xbox 360 people was like yo man
dirt
i i'm getting the ps4 so he actually
writes a clean slate man it's a clean
slate every generation yeah shout out to
the next yeah mpd was briefly discussed
we just said um obviously um elder ring
was best selling game for february 2022
and then um switch was the best selling
console in both units and dollar sale
but behind switch was the series x and
third place was sony so that was
definitely surprising to me again they
they really
saw their last place
doing it
did you see any spaces talking about the
mp
yo you know what it is
i love the dudes that make spaces um
please make a space about that
hey yo
you're ridiculous anyways
[Music]
hold on a second let me just run back
and moji i gotta be quick on it man hot
for the night.com it's out here
you know lonelysingles.com
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
kendrick star 2 super chat media buyers
from greater than naughty dog greater
than nintendo greater than playstation
exclusives because it's everywhere
there we go
heart gate city five dollar super chat
dr pony says media is bought meta is
lies xbox has no games damn it man i'm a
doctor not an analyst oh wait i'm not a
doctor anymore oh my god
i won't be talking about that
then we got dj oros five dollars
hey lord big fan of the podcast i just
wanted to ask if anyone knows when sony
will let me play destiny on steam that
oh
hey bestie i guess he's talking
hey
what's up dj
let me go ahead and do this so uh the
gentleman that won our code
thanks for the giveaway and butchered
the shout out i really don't need the
code please pass it to someone else but
again really appreciate it so we're
gonna go and re-roll that re-roll it i'm
going i'm gonna put another and i'm
going to get in that event
do
what was the last game released for the
original xbox the last the official last
okay okay
you know it
yeah he said do you know
[Laughter]
there was there was miscommunication on
what you guys exactly wanted
i just thought you were just randomly
just off the top like yo
dog said yo just give it to me i'm the
one that worked out i'm done
made the last controller for xbox one
anybody put the answer you got it
madden 09.
so was it america's distinction of the
last game
you uh you have won the 40 dollar uh
gift code yeah i think there are
speculations which you could use this
for what yeah all right the speculators
you got you got to get product get the
powder
you got to get product you can't get the
merch with that you get to go make sure
you get that get the product get the
shower get the showers um
i'm pushing powder out here
let's go
uh we will get you your code man yes
that's right get advanced with it
after soft reads these super chats we
will be doing the the first members
giveaway yes oh there we go if you're a
member please right now subscribe and
join the team yes yes
what you got oh yeah we got a
bearded panda two dollars a chat get em
king get em
hell yeah i got you baby out here pushin
pee i'm done
listen man it's my side hustle man
listen
vs gg get that dude
super chest three it's already 325 i
ain't trying to be for five minutes
somebody get this man get that better
oh good there we go
here comes the non-believer king swing
that she
[Music]
that's funny man
xbox can't win this year because
metacritic tag crossfire x's xbox game
studios and that's a 40. yo
i was reading so the one that dropped
playstation down was destruction
all-stars and that was like a
60-something so yeah a 40 ain't going to
do xbox no favorites this was that
that's published
[Laughter]
did they publish did they publish the
single-player stuff as well small gate i
thought uh remedy
remedy
remedy
we got super chats through these times
[Laughter]
not today we got spartan ghost
super
[Music]
[Laughter]
shout out to you bro yeah
then we got to spend difference again
two dollars
elden ring killed your puppy no dog in
the fight
oh god wow man i love you we were there
for a while in gaming everyone wanted to
make a dog in their game like there was
a dog in everything yeah
yeah fall out had a dog
no doubt continue and we got donald taco
once again five dollar super chat you
can't you can't count sifu as a sony
game without counting games like tunic
shredders warhammer dark tide replaced
somerville slime rancher 2 etc exactly
yeah i got a shout out once i was
finished you know what i should have did
i should have had that um
the pax logo in gold
so your guys can i mean because maybe
the caller is turning you off but if
y'all don't talk i won't know man come
on talk to me man talk to me
and i was like you know what i want it
in gold like our iron lord
we do that over we can do it good to you
and we got spartan ghosts again five
pounds super chat also why was ubisoft
crying about eldon ring it's like popeye
saying they better than a four-star
michelin restaurant sorry but we know
it's never we know it's true
yeah i saw that because they wanted way
points and stuff like that do what you
do
worry about what you do mind your
business
[Music]
of the galaxy on game pass is a big deal
yes it is
a great
and we got joe tour once again joe tour
two five dollars we chat oh gee and five
boroughs fam do y'all miss the arcades
of course like play land in times square
i swear i got served by young justin
wong with street fighter 3 combo and
never i never saw before yeah i mean
the legends used to play in manhattan
like you justin wong all these guys like
yeah that's that's why i don't like
dudes with ponytails to this day i
remember that story time moving on
moving on
hold on a second i got jumped in uh we
got
tai kisarus with the 15 super chat i
reckon with the rating and sales of
elder rings sony and microsoft be like
come over here get some sugar while
bandai namco is like stay i'll cook
clean also i'll do i'll do what you like
just don't leave me wow
possibilities
wasn't there wasn't there a rumor that
microsoft was talking to them about
doing something exclusive i was i never
seen that come out no i think it wasn't
wrong
on the e3 shout out to jeff
yeah
we got the homie big cloud game always
giving me videos to do yes
shout out to big cloud the homie
remember for the 30 months the lord's
stage oh bro he had a huge that
obviously
he had yeah yeah
mickey james
then we got uh
the skills town remember for four months
thank you sir four months in the realm
push that powder wow get that sour bro i
got that sour for you bro that real sour
got that folk focus up baby you're
moving wait
let me let let's let's clarify every
time you say that let's clarify with
advanced teachers
into our beautiful spots
listen i'm getting that urban market
advance gg i know it let me work let me
work
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
40 30 off though
when we get an official iop bars of soap
chill whoa i don't know i told y'all
uh squash
anybody got that connect hit me up
because i use that squash soap uh yo
what's up
you know what was so you know what would
sell we we got that sovereign sparta
or that or daddy stuff oh
i already know man i already know my
promo for that
man what's up see we outside me with
this the size yeah we're gonna have the
shower it's gonna be all steamy i'm
gonna see the hand hit the glass
all right i don't need that i don't need
that level of connection with
you've never seen you've never seen the
squatch one where the dude's in the
shower with his lady yes
wow that's what i'm talking about come
on you're acting like this this ain't
out there but y'all want to see it with
me though let's go let's go moving on
moving on then we got max lazio talk oh
we got that already yeah we got shafiq
baxter five dollar super jack [ __ ]
of play
pushing a game pass day and date game
track to y'all yeah you getting ahead of
us sir you're getting killing us right
here play on playstation play on game
pass no doubt yeah we'll get we'll get
to that momentarily
then we got brian lane two dollars super
chat bought the pack shirt time for
eldon rincog
listen
what is it ted shirts 10 shirts no no no
no no actually it's four more it's four
more shirts yeah y'all ain't gonna hit
that and plus y'all got it i don't see
nobody said that they got that the iron
lord 30 at the checkout yeah
they hit us in the dms though for that
gg.com
and show me your receipt sir got a whole
day for that don't worry about it we're
gonna get him but listen man you send it
make sure you send it to one of us too
so we can hold him because if you send
it to him he might act like he don't see
it
listen they gotta get that iron thirty
and they gotta show me this too trust me
i'll make sure that's right
remember for 21 months thank you so much
stevie lee shout out to you
then we got suicide king it's two
dollars super chat cog just told me my
rupees don't buy his powder
then we got max and lazy and talking
once again five dollars if you chat dirt
and king would be best friends get him
on tts or wbg
yeah we gonna be back
no doubt you don't know
yeah i don't think they saw that first
uh yeah i don't think they did that
first
man yeah it was it was a while ago so we
gotta get you back
we gotta go back in yeah
that was funny that was funny
look at your stevie
how much would it be to see king play a
whole halo
a halo lasso mission all the way through
after he streams elden ring of course
okay okay
let's get to the eldon ring stuff let's
do the ring first boy you going back to
the old stuff don't move we got slobo
back slap five dollars in the chat we
need to see cog waving the seventh
finger in the air for helping elven ring
shout out to the bad co-op system they
[Music]
yeah miyazaki definitely has some issues
we got
shafiq baxter two dollars of attack cog
out here changing his name to avon park
state best product
30 i got the best product out here in
the streets
iron lord 30 on the van gg i'll get that
shower let's go we good we everywhere we
caught up
we're here we're caught up all right
we're going to have other people looking
at this podcast be like yo they're going
real extra maybe we should talk to them
what did it take for him to go there
pandemic let's go all right so we gonna
move on
people that why is firefans though it's
good all right so assad is you man uh
sony state of play what's up yeah they
had uh so because i was laid up for a
little bit i was able to actually watch
the state of play um
and it
wasn't much of anything i think this is
kind of
we can expect this i think this is what
we can expect mostly from state of plays
when they say we have some things to
talk about they don't specifically think
we could expect them this year in
general
yeah
it just
it wasn't a whole lot um a lot of the
stuff they did talk about
was really uh was gonna be on other
platforms so as well so let me do a
quick run through of what they talked
about
so one of the first things that they
talked about are you going to make me
relive this thing really quickly
you're going to maybe go through it
very quickly so first thing they talked
about was uh well maybe it's not an
order um xo primal was that the game the
new game announced from capcom
um multiple yeah multiplied a lot of the
stuff is multiplied a lot of them
one of them is at least one of them is
day one on gameplay
the best looking one tell them the best
[ __ ] one going the game past day one
baby
so uh i you know i don't know if you
guys saw this exo primal for me i'm just
like make dino crisis i don't know right
when i saw the gameplay of this and it's
like all these dino dinosaurs coming out
of like a black hole and you're just
kind of like it it you know i don't know
look generic and and this is the kind of
the issue that i have with a lot of sort
of
japanese centric action games there's
sort of a generic look to some of them
like everything's sort of
kind of mimicking
i don't know like like early like
platinum games and stuff like i don't
know it's just there's something about
it like look over there that they
reference to every time they make it
exactly
and i'm just like i don't know it they
they don't necessarily excite me so for
me you know this doesn't look exciting
to me i would have rather just went back
and did dino crisis once again and going
back to that um actually ghost wire does
look very
i'm interested i'm definitely interested
it looks very cool to me depending on
you know kind of what the story is and
how i want it to be scary so if it's if
it's scary that way i'm gonna be
interested in that so that looked good
um stranger of paradise the final
fantasy origin game uh about the origin
of but the final fantasy one villain
um i downloaded the demo again i was
home so i was like let me see this
bro
oh how was it yeah oh there's a demo
like the gameplay action-wise the
gameplay like it it tries to do kind of
a middle ground between straight action
and kind of the
the the
the hybrid stuff that they had in ff7 in
terms of combat a little bit of that
okay but it's more more action based
but like
the voice acting the story the script is
really bad like it was funny mom shout
out to macho because macho put something
on on on his um
his twitter feed talking about like this
is literally how how like
kindergarteners meet and become friends
because these each of these guys
has like a a black rock that is glowing
and it indicates that they they are
destined to have to fight and defeat
chaos remember
chaos
so they all kind of converged in the
same place at the same time oh you have
a black rock yeah you have a black rock
too oh i guess we're supposed to meet up
to fat chaos and they like they do like
a like a triple fist ball no
they're they're buddies for life and
it's like
it is it is that level of cringe and
cheese that i i know people find
endearing in final fantasy and japanese
games in general i can't i'm done with
it i cannot do it
so i played the demo for like 20 minutes
i was like i'm done i can't like
you got through 20 minutes
yeah
you know what i noticed about a lot of
final fantasy games a lot of square enix
games
ever since that game the the bouncer
remember that yeah oh yeah i remember
that again they
started crafting they look
around how yeah
yeah
and i think that was the because i
thought the bouncer was fantastic
visually and stuff like that yeah and
you know how the world look but it just
seems like they got stuck with that
visual look and they try to import that
on every game pretty much yeah you have
to change it i've seen it for a while
they have to change it because that
generic look is not it man not for me
nah i'm kind of done with it i agree
completely i'm kind of done with it and
it's just like damn i don't know i know
even if the game is cool looking at it
makes it makes me uninterested and it's
like ah yeah i agree with you and then i
just can't with the with the voice
acting like we've taken so many leaps
and bounds and voice acting absolutely
the biggest problem with that game
is just the polish it doesn't look like
there was a whole lot of polish went
into the game it really looks like they
just used the word final fantasy but
it's not yeah it's like it's like
chaos could have been someone completely
different and it wouldn't have mattered
and they're like yo
no one's gonna buy this yo let's put
final fantasy on it you're a genius
yeah so what else then we got a still
account cog huh yeah a t-shirt still
count that one that just came off oh no
that that's not a pax t-shirt sir
but no that's not a problem
as of now there are only two shirts
purchased um shout out to anonymous with
the pax easter egg there needs to be is
three more no as far as i thought it was
ten but when i was moving into five no
it was fine why oh okay i messed you i
don't know where it is coming from here
i don't know where this comes from we're
gonna move on back to let's get back to
the topics let's get back
yeah i interrupted okay
so next up is the recent the recently
delayed fourth spoken got pushed into
the fourth quarter of the year oh they
look dope it looked good it looked good
i i
i want to see what they do with the open
one like any open world game it's like
it's gonna be what's gonna matter is
obviously the combat but what they do in
the open world and if it's interesting
if the character is interesting yeah
like
to me every time i see this game it just
seems like they put her in this open
field with all these ball all these
creatures and she's just like circling
around them and then they just cut right
there that's all we need to show yeah
that's all they show you yeah it did
look more polished than the last time
they did it better than it did last time
didn't look good though i've always
thought the game looked good it's just
like in terms of what they show and like
get me hyped like it just looks like
it it looks like a dlc for final fantasy
15 and they just replace wow that's the
main character
what he's saying is definitely valid um
but it seems interesting yes yeah that
part is i agree
i'm i'm i'm interested there we go
definitely yeah
so next up was a gundam evolution i
don't know anybody on the planet
yeah yeah
that yeah that reminds me of uh uh uh uh
not nintendo yeah nintendo 64.
when remember all the games started
having that block look and then
everything was a first person shooter
and that's i was like who who called for
this
cabbage
it was one of the yeah that definitely
felt like filler you know
and then one of the surprises that i was
super excited for of course me being old
and
the the cowabunga collection the two
days i was fine
[Applause]
that was a great announcement
that was a great announcement it is oh
yeah why are you gonna try to take the
thumbnail right i immediately went
online wait a minute
i immediately went online was like wait
a minute who's this coming to you it was
everybody day one okay fine
so that was that
yeah we did um the shout out to me for
recognizing the condos
to pay attention to a lot of things oh
my god
oh remember we have to sell the day no
you know we need to get back to the
topic to to to cogs um defense
he was out there with platinum games
doing uh yeah he's capturing the big
fish i was down on the floor doing the
little fish and uh hector and i did that
uh review uh we'll interview and the
game looks phenomenal if you guys uh
play the the um what's that monster game
for neo geo um
right
that's what it's like and it's like king
of the monsters for our generation on
steroids i was so happy to see it on a
playstation platform but again on a
multi-player
yeah but he definitely multiplied it
shout out to doing a promotion for us
jojo's bizarre adventures coming back
capcom 2d fighter uh i remember seeing
this game way back in the day and be
like this is gorgeous it's weird but
it's gorgeous um
back in the heyday of like the capcom
fighting games on dreamcast yes and the
saturn and stuff like that so
it's coming back it's good
yeah it looks very good i guess this is
so this is
no it's not no no it's a multifunction
[ __ ] everything that looked dope is for
everybody
[Laughter]
but we're looking we're looking at like
a 50 character roster this time yeah
really crazy so it's a remake of the
original bizarre adventure but just uh
they you know pumping it up to like a
thousand so yeah
that's gonna be cool to see
the next thing they talked about is the
one that we were talking about as a game
pass day one game trek oh let's go put
your hands fine
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it looks amazing
get inside game pass
you don't have to pay a nickel shout out
for stata for the street stay for the
streets
state of the street oh yeah track to
your meat yeah go ahead
i was gonna say it is kind of funny
because though you know a lot of people
are really excited for that game yeah
but then when i saw the after effect
when it's like oh it's on game pass it's
like the excitement for playstation just
went down are you are you implying that
certain people tied their excitement to
a potential exclusivity of that title uh
i don't even think it's that i just
think it's like
people value money over everything it's
just like the moment that you show me
that i could play something for just the
subscription already paid for
then it's just like then at that point
it's not playstations anymore it's
xboxes
was like yo we got one son we got you
see the ghost is just singing massage
scrolling it's about
it's going
[Laughter]
when they sign deals for these marketing
rights and then they find out later it's
a game pass i would talk about it
yeah all right so next up we have so
tricky on me looks great and once again
devolver digital just continues to
publish bangers they they really
absolutely they don't miss a lot um
didn't want them to call it purchase
them or will purchase a percentage of
them 10 cents
of devolver
yeah yeah yeah did they you know it's a
good question yeah i got
i have that somebody hit me with that go
ahead sorry uh then we got dlc for
return or return ascension that was good
i like that
yeah that's cool and it's free
yeah that'll go yeah i look good
i think i think that's the biggest part
it's stupid and that's a maya copa for
for amir copper for the fact that it was
the ship broken and breaking the
consoles
give them anything bro like damn
so you know the fact that they hushed
the company you know from telling the
truth the company was like listen i'll
be quiet if you put this out for free
oh you feel about when you talk about
when what's that company was it
housewalk that made that yeah well
they were everybody was bad at housewalk
about the crashing and then house walk
said
they did kind of throw something out of
us with that
these consoles can't handle us oh yeah
and then right after that they got
purchased and there was a cease and
desist on they they were oh that's how
it went okay that's like they marry her
now she can't testify be quiet
continue
so then the final two things they talked
about this is a very square enix centric
uh state of play were uh two games two
new games from square enix the first one
themselves don't got nothing
so their daddy square enix is coming
through for them we got the deal field
the deal field chronicles which is very
much in the vein
of a
fire emblem type of game so uh
so um
yeah that's kind of the first time we
see something like that on the
playstation platform i believe it's this
one i'm not sure i don't remember seeing
it one of them is exclusive one little
screen is games it's an exclusive one as
a multiplayer i don't remember which one
i think it's deal field i think it's
this one right and i think the next one
valkyrie was the exclusive the elysium
okay yeah then we everyone is exclusive
yeah
the the one that looked like it was a
playstation 4 type the the one that
looks like tactics type of gameplay
that's a multi-player
so that is like another game in that
vein but it has you know you don't have
to put a ring on that one a little more
graphical oomph than uh than maybe uh so
dial field is multi-platform
yeah okay
with that
and then we have
the sequence of the exclusive the worst
looking joint out there was this
we got valkyrie elysium which is which
is a sequel to valkyrie profile 2 and we
have which we haven't seen a valkyrie
profile game like
it's shout out to dirk because he talked
about the ps2 the ps2 had so many
freaking games on it um yeah the last
one to come out in the valkyrie series
was profile two and that was like in
2006.
um so we have not seen a valkyrie
profile esque game in a very long time
there's probably a reason for that i
know why you saw it right you saw what
it looked like
it's one of those again it's it's ps4
ps5 so you know it's crosstalk they're
trying to get me to buy this ld oh they
tweeting me that sour on twitter
with the cold
they like
we're done so that was it it was kind of
mostly uneventful not a lot of stuff to
really write home about
um
again the multi-plat stuff that i was
excited about you know the turtle stuff
the trip the trek to yomi that sort of
stuff um and the jojo's bizarre
adventure for me anyway everything else
kind of just fell flat for me and
returned obviously getting co-op finally
getting co-op and some plc is very good
as well yeah
the free is good yeah let me jump in my
boss yeah you gotta put your wedding on
them so hard because i'm probably gonna
be the only dissenting opinion in here
look i thought the journey was fine i
liked it i liked it really yeah i liked
it i liked it i liked it a lot i'm a
japanese game supporter so for me you
know exo promo look decent i'm a
japanese game supporter but not them
japanese
don't do that don't do that that's fine
listen i would love for xbox to have a
show like this i mean for me personally
i agree i like maybe it's because i i
expect a lot from playstation in terms
of japanese support right so like it's
if these were on xbox stage i i would
definitely i'd have been doing a
backflip i'm like let's go agree with
you yeah i mean actual problem
and then you gotta look at it from like
because it was so square
i'm expecting the ones i want to
actually see too like final fantasy xv
sure
yeah for me it was like that like i said
i like that it kind of had like a
warframe anthem mix kind of vibe you
know i'm about my co-op and you know to
hold the frame rate low i don't know
dinosaur
we gotta talk now i've been
ghost ride tokyo is one of the weirdest
feelings for me when i first saw the
game i'm like yeah i mean it looked
horrible then the second time i saw it i
was like no i don't want i actually
thought the first time i saw it it
looked horrible and then
and the more i see it the more i want it
like it went from like a one to three to
a five to a seven the first time the
first time we saw it was at the
beginning
the first time i saw it at the showcase
in e3 at the bethesda show being caught
i was like yo that looked fire right
yeah and then you had you had the
director at the time year
right everything about it you can do the
interview for this game no no no no no
no i ain't get a chance to go to that
one what interview did you do because
okay what's up i got to be confused yeah
you're confused with another game i know
it's not that one i know which one you
talk about it's just you talk about the
samurai joint yeah that's a different
one but you get to jump from space to
yeah
different different joints
that was um
so this one
yo stitch is fine he said cog is high on
his own supply you stupid anyway um
you're not gonna do that go get that
sour stop it stop it go get that sour
iron lord 30. i'm not on that type of
time but continue um so look
ghostbuster
goes wide tokyo
looked fire to me that wow look now the
hand gestures the spiritual joint and
then i like they got the little mass
ninja dudes with the hoodies you know
what i'm saying like i was feeling it
gave me some vibes it looked it was very
unique it's just different you know what
i'm saying so and to king's gonna laugh
i mean i know that's coming to xbox at
some point for the for the game pass so
it's like remind me of def loop because
yeah like
duke they mattered
wait wait it's day one there's no way
day one
i'm talking
it's just so cool though that i was like
okay that's going to come to get past
and that's the joy that's fine so that i
don't care what nobody say that force
spoke to me i'm feeling it i'm feeling
it it look cool very rare to see a very
cool looking female black protagonist
the powers look crazy i like the
abilities she you know where it was for
me ken
did you see the part where she had the
surfboard she was doing the silver surf
over the water with the mystic poplar i
was like they got me that was for me
that was for me
yeah and i was like this game looked
good yeah shout outs
they gave sarah barn powers and put her
in the game i'm in so i'm all awake
i low-key feel like that game's about to
like get like a high 70 early 80. okay
yeah i believe you could yeah
it just depends on how they how they
tell the story because i see the story
but you know that's not appealing for me
i'll be in my hashtag just one and it
just fits all the boxes so i'm all about
it so um they can keep that just one you
are messy stop it so what i was going to
say it's called drop the powder like
it's at the top it should be pinned to
the chat this is that the link's at the
top go get this out um
don't laugh i i i kind of thought
god damn i was i was it gave me old
school it gave me some g1 trans the
graphics is wacky yeah this car nato
shirt
looks good because it remind me you know
what i'm reminding you you just said
gundam yeah
somebody shut his mic over here
bro they remind me of if y'all play har
moon studio transformers the g1 joints
the multiplayer joints like there was a
point where they gunned them transformed
into a little plane and they jumped out
it was both our player transformers g1
to be i was like yo i might be in on
that oh and it's multi-platform
he he does this every so okay dirt let
me tell you about [ __ ] he does this fake
hype for something fake
would come out and he act like he didn't
see it like
if the rating is whack any review then
yeah i'm not going to talk about it
though
i can't be hyper if they're disappointed
but anyway move it on but for me yes
definitely
trek the yummy that's all that's ninja
style that's samurai is giving me soup
yeah see gabe has okay yep seafood you
know what it reminded me of it reminded
me of
yes that gameplay vibe like the
side-scrolling game playbob you have to
be precise precisely and all that stuff
yeah 2d souls a little bushido blade
a little bit of seafood with the
mysticalness like you he got murdered
his his family they ravaged his town and
the dude killed him already and he
looked like he going through some
spiritual joint to get back to his body
or something i don't know what's going
on the game looked fine apparently they
got a really good question
yes it's fire
a generic
like gundam battlefield like all right
it could be a mobile situation but it
really looks like the mobile game like
it looked like something my brother
would play on his tablet like
they got me with the
[Laughter]
i don't know why it appealed to me but
anyway so that at last was returned over
a turtle i might have to actually get it
out of the bushes because i was very mad
we're really dope about me what i never
purchased it never supported it when i
buy the game it's gonna be ten dollars
and i'm gonna have the whole dope
package
absolutely man i i love listen you you
add that type of joint then they got the
co-op for me and a new campaign
and halo take notes if you're gonna put
the campaign for some new content
because nobody won't play that old kid
yeah that's dope see that's what you do
that's what's gonna happen there's gonna
be more than two people that's all i'm
saying so that that's pretty much all i
got on that did you try to compare that
to that no i'm just saying i just like
the fact that their campaign was late
and they added new content with their
co-op
how about when you add co-op you add new
narrative content
again maybe they could have won
something anyway and yeah we made hustle
we mentioned that kyle bunga's edition
yeah that was fire that was filed
definitely all right so we're moving on
so i'm starting to chat and then we did
the last one yeah
my balls are falling
oh
i'm sorry
and i found out right after everything
there was for the street side
i thought it was all right and i knew
the worst looking game was exclusive you
know what that means phil looked at it
was like y'all could keep that
shout out to putting people to sleep for
the first 20 minutes wow dope about it
is
i watched it through attic and hustle
right because i was doing some stuff and
i was going to be on with addict and
hustle but attic
and hustle's watching it and hustle is
so cool i love the way hustle you know
and attic play off each other because
hustle was a little bit earlier and he
knew that he was a little bit advanced
in the video than attic was
um because he tried to re-um
refresh the screen but it didn't work
right but hustle's so cool of a dude
that when he saw something that was
shocking to him he'll do this
yeah
you know so so adam can catch up so it
was really good
yo y'all go check that out watch they
stay the uh the state of the streets
over there on attic joint stays in the
streets
because that's what they are now so we
ain't gonna act like every state of play
hasn't been stated the streets because
they've been doing this for a long time
they give you the false narrative like
they're showing exclusive stuff and it's
not it's for the streets everybody in
there everybody gonna eat they have one
or two games that's dead joints and
usually they're the worst joints of the
show so
i had fun watching it knowing that game
pass is going to be truly lit and the
game that i was excited for the most
is day one in game pass shout out to
phil for having the state of the streets
out there sponsored by microsoft it was
done
oh that was what i'm gonna say it was
just that i thought that was interesting
okay because that was the first time it
was a game pass deal but it was marketed
so i'm like does the div
does devolver get in two bags like
because they were marketable you know
what i'm saying and then they know they
got the game pass during and microsoft
seem cool with it so i want to know if
that's gonna be a wave that's a very
interesting thing to track yeah yeah i'm
gonna start seeing here in the next
probably year year and a half
all these old contracts that they signed
years ago
to to work on these titles they're going
to put clauses in these new contracts
this doesn't go to game pass
see the thing is these games were made
years ago like these deals were made
years ago so yeah now you're going to
start seeing these new deals and
microsoft making game pass is going to
naturally make sony pay more to keep
stuff off game pass with getting the
marketing day and that leads into my
next topic
good
so we ready for these thank you addict
you set that up wonderfully
let me read these super chats let me
give you super
[Music]
okay we're going to do the first members
question
and it's going to be how much money did
microsoft purchase rare for
oh
that's a good question i remember that
and some dudes might say too much money
but what i would say is sea of thieves
paid for itself
yeah let me see if he's doing well yeah
very well you have to have a green icon
besides your name to get this two
dollars shut up crystal
because we're crazy
that's my dude how was your state of the
street
you saw a lot of stuff that you gonna
buy
yo
chris i saw a lot of stuff i'm gonna try
but
a lot of stuff that you're going to buy
you see the difference how i use those
words
i know that's my dude
and we have a winner tony brown right
yeah
he got it no doubt so hit me up on
twitter uh tony it'll be about twitter
oh good song and we will after
before the next topic starts we'll do
the second members once you you guys can
get in this man you got to join uh join
the realm and you can be uh have access
to this giveaway i love giving back to
people to actually you know participate
in that manner i love everybody that's
here sometimes financially you can't
participate like that but if you can't
get in that's what i say man no doubt
so up you ready yep
we got uh brian lane two dollar super
chat
eldon cox selling powder in a town near
you
they really try to get me to play that
real quick tony said that he doesn't
need it uh past mine uh my own i already
got my pal
you're good yo you go ahead i got that
sound that's my boy tony right he'll be
waiting
the suicide king could get ahold of me
on twitter because you answered it right
after he did suicide no doubt suicide
yeah so
we got slow-mo back slap five dollar
super chat i just picture cog sitting by
a campfire in limwell offering advanced
cg products to every tarnish that rides
by
[Laughter]
go to something like sea of thieves and
just like every person's like yes
this advanced gg best gg baby
like how how good how did you get so
good at seeing these this advanced gg
[Laughter]
we gotta have a video of him uh using
the focus right before he played elderly
oh god
i'm gonna have to do that good there we
go we got freddy fox freddy fox
oh he used
hello lords definitely gotta get king
back on wbg and i need a collab of king
with the pony voice and dirt with his
pony crying skit that will be fire oh
yeah those two baby
[Music]
play was cool because it gave me some
good games to look out for on my xbox's
switch
maybe the next one they'll give me
something to play on my ps5 we'll see
then taco again two dollar super chat
i thought valkyrie elysium was a vita
game
wow oh wow i'm not gonna lie it was the
most barren looking game i thought it
was a nintendo 64 game
wow that's what it looks like shout out
to the 650 wow that has joy
listening all foolishness definitely
that like button man let's get that up
to over four years
get that up to
right now you 400
it out when we get to fifteen thousand i
mean fifteen hundred subscribers mm-hmm
well you know fifteen thousand fifteen
hundred
fifteen thousand subscribers we're
giving away another console yeah we get
another one um so start sending that
stuff yeah we're close to 12 right
[Laughter]
seems like you're pushing listen
oh i'm moving sour that's all i see well
i mean
on the on the actual box i mean on the
label it says
that's what the product says
you pop these pills
powder it's literally powdered ain't
that right
man
okay get that birthday cake
this is pure this is pure cut i like i
you can't do that on street
[Music]
i'm done
listen man the price of the focus went
up let's go that's funny yeah my
brother's keeper that's right
con artistic 10 super jet cog full
disclosure i voted yes for you to play
elden ring
even though i still haven't got it
myself oh also
i got that style over 30 off because you
piqued my interest hit that like button
blessings off bless the brother yo i'll
tell you once you get them showers bro
i'm telling you bro so i'm gonna tell
you don't wait till tomorrow yeah
tomorrow the price go down 30 percent
off now
going up that's so crazy tomorrow it's
gonna be crazy
you only had three days man
it's moving out here too
don't lose [ __ ]
time don't lose focus
get focused
mm-hmm
yeah we got uh donald taku two dollars
of chat tmnt trek and dealfield were the
only hits for me yes sir you played them
on that switch i know i know how you
think
then we got mandingo mixture
yeah
he's outside
dollar super chat i didn't realize that
sony released crazy taxi 2 on the ps5 oh
man come on man are you doing gt7 like
that that's a dude
facts hurt you stop snitching cia open
up you ain't got no license from us to
distribute power
he's messing that's that's the better
question how's sony going to do gt7 like
that
yes
there we go
hard to find two dollars they have to
pay they have to pay me to play that
gundam game
i might be getting that on the low i
ain't going for that
i think they have paid betas
[Laughter]
there we have uh donald taco again five
dollars super chat we knew that check
the yomi was coming to game pass since
last year though that's true that they
actually we saw tractor you only a long
time ago there we go yeah wrong with
that we just
affirming what was gonna happen you
gotta know
that's day one which is why
i would see it i never thought i would
see it on the playstation event yeah
i i'm glad it was there y'all bye we
tried let's go
[Laughter]
that's gonna be that game
y'all buy we try let's go
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
let's go we all stars
[Music]
[Laughter]
you didn't get that advanced gj that's
it man fiorina cut we got something
there one more look at metroid two
dollars we checked cog is stacking money
in colombia
eskimos
let's go let's go all right so we're
going to say when you take a sip you got
to look at the camera smile or not with
the thumbs up you're stupid all right
call well go we'll find out some chat
what flavor advanced gg yeah sour the
sour apples huh you got to get the salad
i said they got the sour grape i mean
the um the
apple joint too but this the sour um
just the watermelon jump off just the
water yeah all right no doubt so we got
last one for man
man go make thickens 10 super chat can
someone tell me how elden ring
playstation sales only outsold sony
exclusives according to these sony guys
that's impossible i guess grand taxi 7
and horizon forgotten jess got mixed
with scoring less than 90 oh my god
we talking that trash
it is what it is actually i have x x
abbott two dollars super chat if i buy
three bricks can i can i get a book yeah
yo if you bought it three get the three
bricks flip them with iron lord 30 or
advantage let me give you the link and
you can get them bricks for you you want
on the powder
[Laughter]
i got you bro i got you we're moving it
we're moving i'm trying to make partners
let's try to move up this ladder man
they got me they got they got me on the
side blocks i'm trying to move up
yo yo
you're gonna have people messaging
advanced gg i thought this was different
kind of powder
focus here focusing all right so we go
all right so final topic you know crazy
long um this is a big one
shout out to uh my boy michael pachter
um yeah this was this was uh this was a
hot one
yeah
king demanded it so um according to
michael pack first of all let's shout
outs give um dealer gaming rdx podcast
they flowers because this actually
happened on rdx shout out to them shout
out the dealership tim dawg von zaka d
badge the crew you know what i'm saying
but yeah the question is is playstation
doomed and this was [ __ ] up at king's
laughing um with uh michael pack the you
know industry analyst he's been out
there with uh web bush securities so um
the subject came up and he said
according according to pact microsoft
has an insurmountable lead in services
infrastructure and overall ecosystem
that is future-proof xbox for the next
10 years sony on the hand doesn't have
that kind of lasting power at least
that's what michael practice believes he
quote he says and unquote i think
playstation is doomed and i think they
are going to cease to exist as we know
them in about 10 years
they can't compete they have no chance
then he went on to say
they've got a huge head start now
the 17 million ps files as of december
microsoft hasn't released a number but
you know it's eight or less playstation
is going to pass like they're standing
still not in console sales and game pass
numbers microsoft has 25 million game
pass users without activision how many
are they going to get with activision
there is so much content sony is not
just a couple years behind it's an
insurmountable
leak
this has set twitter on fire
um for disclosure you know people have
come at michael pachter for some wrong
predictions in the past yeah but this is
a hot one man let's give it to dirk like
what where are you at with this you know
is playstation doomed
well i don't want to use the word doom
right because he said as we know them
hold up dirt we we want messi don't no
no no you don't want corporate dirt
i'm not going to say the word doom right
but i will say that he's right about one
thing they are behind when it comes to
the services because xbox game pass is
only going to get better he already said
it
they're at 25 million without activation
so imagine when
the deal is finalized yearly annual call
of duty
even though it will remain multiplied
it's going to be in this service
meanwhile the playstation guys are going
to have to pay 70 bucket rules for it
that's going to catch on right even for
the casuals that prefer playstation or
even maybe some of the hardcore guys
eventually yo man i love cod but
bruh it's in the surface on xbox game
pass and play says i gotta pay 70. no no
that's not going to add up
um
i just feel that they have to do
something quick
because as years go
playstation i mean they have a hell of a
brand strong brand you know they have
great exclusives worldwide they're
definitely the more popular brand but
let's not just assume
like how you said every generation is
different let's not just assume that all
of the playstation fans are going to be
there no i know the the playstation
fanboys will but
some people might say yo man xbox is
looking like the better place to be at
the moment
because
we don't want playstation to be like a
blockbuster or blackberry right we don't
know like i know you guys heard those
analogies before but we don't want those
like i like playstation mm-hmm
i really do i don't want them to go
anywhere
when you look at what mike department
what what he's saying there's some valid
you know things there
uh they're behind on on services okay so
he said uh
as we know them right
see that's a that's a telling that's a
telling
phrase right as we know as we know them
right so what would they turn into
well if if if we see them for who they
are today as the the
the developer
the console distributor
the platform holder
what would they change into if they do
would you say they would turn into a
third party like
he's trying to go you're saying that
this has been his narrative for about
[Music]
you shall
reap what you sow
you know
uh
the end isn't it i've been i've
prophesized it long time ago the swami
have seen it
and i've said it but y'all needed this
man
to ride on my coattails to tell you well
you guys said it first i will give you
guys
you know individuals are afraid
to step up and say that shout out to
michael pachter
for giving life to my words
all right it makes me king
like but the word doom though you know
that word
[Music]
oh
i'm saying like you see it right you got
those eyeballs they did it's doom
it's doom because it's an insurmountable
task that's set in front of him that's
17 million means nothing to that 25
million games but see
there we go papoo in that number of 25
million we're going to stop doing that
because that is the app
for the people that are in in the
subscribe we're not talking about the
ones that's on trials and stuff right
now
so so you're looking at eight million of
those dudes
microsoft don't want to count them we
count them when they turn into you know
the regulars
you know you don't count the guys that
sometimes come through because that's
sometime money mm-hmm
you gonna count the for show cash show
money yeah so
dirk go back to what you said
i like how you said it because you said
it it just woke me up i'm so apologetic
for jumping into your segment i do sorry
apologize like no that's fine bro that's
fine but like you said
well let me say this like i said he has
some valid points in there
um they can compete financially with
xbox microsoft and as we see microsoft
is 100 behind xbox so
for them to be able to recover
um i don't know if they can i
i'm not going to say boom be doomed
yeah
yeah
i just can't see
i guess i'm going by their brand at the
moment being right so popular but
like i mentioned earlier
it is no guarantee it's going to stay
that way that's true
this industry hell any industry
the customers is that what have you done
for me lately
yes yes
have you ever had a panasonic television
yeah back in the day
can you go buy one now absolutely not
exactly yeah
brands die all of the time yes
absolutely we all know like xbox was
almost out of here you know the fact
though
yeah brands like all of the time so phil
brought it up
yeah so i understand why he's only
begotten son yes we don't dominate
his feelings
definitely save
you said my man is soft and he kissed
babies yeah he out here he do that
you're kissing babies and shaking hands
right now you're looking at that game
pass remember he clowned me and told me
halo was a stand up inside dave and
busters
i want you back all right so clearly
you're gonna get grabbed my gear back
it's hilarious yeah
so at the end of the day um
i understand where he's coming from and
you know part of me agree
part of me doesn't want to fully agree
yet yeah
there's a little hesitant yeah i see
there you know but i understand where
he's coming from i guess i'm just going
by the brand the playstation brand but
like king said there's plenty of brands
that we loved in the past that's not
around anymore because for whatever
reason they didn't uh evolve they didn't
innovate that's the [ __ ]
and that's the fact brother like i
always say that you know like the
blackberry analogy they it was stubborn
they didn't want to innovate and iphones
came out and smacked them and do you
know anybody got a blackberry i don't
know that's a fact
good point oh yeah that's right man
obama
yo
stop it
europe man the playstation
the bachelor pack the comments is
playstation dude
uh no i don't think they're doomed uh
the thing is is i think
i think
sony themselves even know that you know
they are
practicing a
a formation like a tradition that isn't
going to last forever that's why they're
doing like spartacus and stuff like that
i do feel like they're going to wait to
the last moment till they see
you know the the actual landscaping
start shifting
then they're going to come out and be
like yo spartacus
are games coming out there in day and
day uh i think that's when they're
they're building the building blocks to
if stuff goes south
they'll go with it but until it starts
going south i don't think they're going
to really change anything up the
difference between them and a company
like blockbuster or panasonic like
they didn't
prematurely build blocks they just
assumed that the market was not
but but it never did like it was just
the way things were at that point going
on but like i get it
they are feeling like wow
wow the walls was on fire they just
sitting there cool with a bucket of
water just in case it's just they got
the bucket of water jessica they had a
bucket get too close they had a bucket
of water like sony's sony's making a
device to flush the whole wall
all right so
blockbuster sonic was shooting it with a
squirt gun okay so sony is building the
device what if the device malfunctions
or jams because a lot of dude goes into
gun fights and they gun jam
hey king but you're right see the ammo
is very important and the ammo
they will not have no call of duty ammo
on their guns though right right never
that's never
spotted because they never had call of
duty boy you gonna love damn
i think i think the
look like obviously they're behind on
services you still can't even gift on
playstation that that's horrible like
people's like oh you can't do it on
switch no one expects to do it on switch
right
it's just like playstation needs to take
those kind of features more seriously
and i feel like until they do people
aren't really going to take them a whole
lot serious now i i don't think they're
doomed because at the end of the day
they still make quality games and
regardless how people feel they're going
to go where those games are all the
quality games that they did last year
that they came up short
developers yeah
now as far as
like regardless how that goes king like
do you have a playstation 5. um
and it got mad dustpanic
do you have a playstation 5 yes i have
one called yes i have one yes yeah so i
don't have one yet added so okay are you
trying to get a point
i'm trying to get one yeah yeah i am
trying to get one so it's the reason you
don't have one is because of
shortage supplies absolutely
absolutely so at the end of the day
five out of five people have a ps5 but
he do have a we're the minority though
bro i mean
he have a series x though don't you play
absolutely you have a series x right so
check this out it's not it's not he
doesn't have a playstation 5 for lack of
effort you understand he he tried and he
was just like whatever
but but i'm going to tell you right now
he was not he was not going to let that
series x walk past
him
hyperbole you ain't gonna sit here and
try to spin your narrative and talk
about do you have a playstation 5. yes
we do a lot of people do and they could
be sold and traded and pushed on for the
next but at the same time we ain't going
to talk about console cells we already
know they're 17. we already know they're
leading in that but they're deficient in
other areas and there's other areas is
going to be their detriment and that
detriment is going to be their doom
double oh those eyeballs
and playstation was doing why do you
have the ps5
jesse with the hardcore though listen so
you bought a ps5 with no attention on
using it no i brought a ps5 for
spider-man
okay i played miles morales i
listen i have but engagement is what
pushes numbers i'm the dude they don't
want they don't want me they don't want
me to have a place they should five
inside the house like we have no
playstation now
i don't have a playstation now
subscription i don't have a playstation
plus subscription i don't engage with
them on any format to me
they don't want me they would rather me
sell mine to somebody that's going to
use this
assuming something is doomed is assuming
that no one would want that product uh
you got doom they're all okay can you
let me finish
wrong
in order for something to be doomed no
one will want that problem
long as they make games that people
desire that product won't be doomed now
i will agree with you if you don't if
they don't address the stuff when it
comes to
the services and the basic features that
should be on playstation they might
definitely be
the second console the the call to
people like the switch oh i got the xbox
for all the third-party stuff for the
game pass i got the playstation for
whatever they decide to release stuff
that might
very well happen but to say that it will
be doomed i just don't agree because
they
in order for them to be doomed they'd
have to be zero
desire for that platform and as long as
they make games like spider-man like go
sushima like last of us like these games
are going to generate hype and they're
going to degenerate any form of desire
for this platform and i don't think it
can truly be doomed until that
want is gone
soft now you're up sir
doomed is it over throw it in time
myself because i wanted you to get your
balls off
he could he couldn't help him he could
help himself i could help myself but i
want him to get his balls off so i have
stuff to retort but see this is in you
know in rap battles
they allow the individual to talk
without interrupting so you can rebuttal
my rebuttal game is sickening
so much it's
so
this playstation duped
we all know pack right we know
why you said it like that we did beat me
shout out the pack yeah
yeah yeah you got a big bottle you got
that big bottle of whiskey on it when we
saw him at e3 that's my dude salute
what he had in his hand stop snitching
oh yeah yeah
right there
yeah
is respected for a reason right he is
respected for a reason at the same time
he knows the audience he's talking to
and he was on on rdx you know
he knows what he he knows how to get a
ride i got him he knows how to get a
rise i'm just saying pax is very good at
that right he's been wrong before mm-hmm
let me finish king yeah
i'm muting myself
no you don't need to mute yourself
because you might agree with me more
than you think oh okay what happened i
don't know
to say it that way they're doomed
you have to caveat it with they're
doomed if they don't make the proper
moves they need to make to address the
deficiencies
that are becoming more and more obvious
every day
when you when you start to compare
what microsoft is doing how they're
moving and again it only matters if the
market accepts it
we're coming upon 30 million some on gay
pride subscribers whatever the case may
be the market accepts it
meaning and and the thing is when you
think about
where media distribution has been going
for the past decade
the writing was already on the wall when
it when we talk about how we consume our
music how we consume our movies
all of this how we consume our
television now all of this was writing
on the wall it was just a matter of time
before somebody in the gaming space did
it in in the way that and fair to be
fair maybe microsoft and maybe valve are
the only ones that can do it to this
level right
so when you talk about
they're doomed it's like well
they have to do something
comparative right they can't do it in
the same way that microsoft does it
because they just they would not spend
that amount of money right
absolutely that makes sense so i it
always takes me back to this idea of
activision blizzard and the idea that
they're being you know they're being
investigated and all this stuff and and
and the whole monopoly talk right
the monopoly isn't in the amount of
studios that they have and the amount of
of of sort of ip that they now own
the problem when you start talking about
unfair practices right and
non-competitive practices
game pass is where that problem could
arise for them because game pass if they
are putting as much money as we think as
they are in game pass right money that
sony would never invest
then they're swimming in waters where
they know that competition can't go
right that is a non-competitive practice
there that is doing something
in the scope of this industry that your
competition cannot hope to follow you in
right so
the end of the day
sony has to they have to mimic what's
happening in just
the distribution of media period games
whatever they have to mimic that they
have to do it the sony way in a way that
makes sense for them to continue to make
money
so if they don't do that and they
continue to look on the sideline and be
like hey they can't do what nintendo
does they can't they can't they cannot
be nintendo and be like we don't care
what they're doing they can't do that
because they're all they've always been
the conversation with
these are the two tops right these are
the ones that are really i know people
can leave nintendo out of the
conversation which is unfair because a
lot of ways they make that money
but
they can't afford to stand on the
sideline and be like the 70 games are it
for for the foreseeable future they
can't they have to do something i don't
know how comparable it's gonna be
but they have to do something so when he
says doomed
it's doomed if they sit on their hands
for sure right
and i don't think they'll do that now
will they will they find that again if
microsoft continues to swim in these
waters that they can't swim in
will we start seeing
their first party games day and date and
whatever services they have
might they transition to something more
of a service if they feel like being in
the in that space and being the platform
holder doesn't behoove them anymore
because microsoft with the amount of
things that they purchase and own or
whatever it's just so easy for everybody
to be like hey we're just going to go to
get xbox they have everything that's a
that's a likelihood that could happen
so i'm going to be honest man
he's not wrong
doomed is a strong word but they they
i'm surprised they haven't
they haven't spoken they haven't really
they themselves haven't spoken on the
existence of
of spartacus right right everybody else
yeah the room is out
so they gotta move that's it you have to
i'll jump in if let's agree with sad by
the way yeah i'm i'm on that type of
time look
keg i know where you go and i know this
this this is your thing you've been on
it you've been predicting it i didn't
trust me i didn't get a chance to spill
my spill yet oh my phone you wanna get
your balls off get your balls
let him go you're gonna get him going
i'll go laughs
i'll just close it off
because that's no job
i'm listening to everybody and
i'm hearing you mm-hmm
but i'm not feeling you that feeling all
right
i don't i don't got to feel you pause
um
i actually don't
um i've been more right than i've been
wrong i'm not passionate generation
i'm not packing yeah right so so when
dudes look at pacter they're gonna go
look at him he's he's a industry analyst
yes
so he goes by statistics and he goes by
margins so i'm pretty sure he's more
right than he is wrong he just has a lot
more predictions that he has to do
in order to achieve that number my
number is 97 right
all right so that three percent y'all
are begging and hoping that my three
percent wrong will be this
it won't be
it won't be because y'all are the same
dude i told you
and you know a lot of times dudes be
like oh king don't be doing that uh
console war stuff no no no no no no no
let me tell you something
this is for every sega kid oh god man
you're busting your gun for sake yes
because they kill you
for every okay master system dude for
every tower of power with god
for every dream cast they got uh
his life cut short
for the damn maturity for the day
let
how his life got cut short nobody ever
talks about how the dreamcast life got
cut short it wasn't the power it wasn't
the tools because microsoft was in that
box so it wasn't that it wasn't the
greatest launch library in the history
of video games no it was disgusting
practices that undercut its legs
right
they took out the quarterback
all right so
the rest of the team couldn't function
they took his legs out they did a chop
block on my man
they boxed them out
sony was doing stuff in the background
that boxed them out that price
yeah
they did things to themself as well yep
so what we're watching right now and
y'all not seeing it you're not reading
the tea leaves they're doing things to
themselves as well
they had a state of the streets right
now can you dig it they had a state of
the streets right now yeah catch that
wrestling pro bowl guy
looking stuff is available someplace
else
i told y'all
while y'all bi
we try at what point in time is that
going to seek into your head to
understand that don't see it's a mind
state
there's a conditioning
i keep hearing i say stuff like oh
what they used to
do well we hope they do
y'all relied on gran turismo being gran
turismo it came out it's not gran
turismo what's happening to you right
now
y'all had a staple that was dead that
was not a staple anymore people are
complaining because the business
practices they're gouging you
they're not giving back to you there's a
reason why i said return was fantastic
that dlc 10 is free it's whatever it's
free for you
those practices right there keeps the
core base there at what point of time
does the core base look over to the
competition and say i am not valued here
but over there i am valued this is where
the mindset changes it doesn't matter if
you buy a playstation and it sits there
you are not the target audience for that
captivator right there because they want
you at what all console
developers want
is your engagement
the more you engage with that machine is
the more likelihood you are apt to
purchase and stay in the ecosystem and
transcend two dollars i am a detriment
to them i am a dead box to them you
understand they can't track me yo jim
ryan didn't say that he didn't he didn't
like so now what pacter is trying to
tell you is the lead is so heavy
when activision games start popping in
what he's seeing is
when it's the month to month movements
of microsoft they cannot compete
so what happens when jim dance moves
ryan looks over and he says
you know where we're losing the most
money
research and development on consoles
what are we really making the most money
on our software
so if we can get our software everywhere
that's when the game changer happens
that's when they say i told you long
time ago there's not gonna be a
playstation sex yeah you've been on your
square yeah yeah you've been saying that
the only worse than i ever seen
this console generation is going to last
at eight to ten years we are three years
behind because of the pandemic yeah
that's about i think this generation
does go longer yeah right so this one
it's going to go long and pulse it's
going to be what it's going to be and by
the end of this generation the level of
competition will be none
because
as you saw
in a year that was a down year microsoft
got developer of the year for a 12-year
reign nobody has done this thing that
they have done
and remember sony bus early in the
beginning of last year they bust early
at the beginning of this year as well
got a war and y'all know god of war
coming out this year
all right so so there goes your hopes
spent on next year bus early dudes the
bus early dudes let somebody else finish
the rest of the year off
and that's how you be remembered
this generation they'll step behind in a
step too slow this is the time when the
champ is not the champ no more how many
times did y'all look up at that team
that screamed and realized buster
douglas is who the guy that beat mike
tyson when mike tyson was the undefeated
on
a monster
look like he couldn't be beat that was
ps4 generally put that lump on his eye
and put him to sleep
oh [ __ ] you got tabs laughing in the
chat when he said that microsoft is our
buster douglas
he ain't taking it you're not hearing it
i think a little better than busted okay
no but you know buster
[Music]
y'all think phil dominance maximus
really is spencer is scared with
microsoft backing that money isn't it
i agree with jack i think he's more holy
field than buster yeah
that's nice
but i'm talking about this is one fight
this is one generation this fight is
this generation
that's what you're doing they say holy
[ __ ] i'm never the same after that this
is what i'm trying to tell you okay
that's where you're going all right so
i told y'all before but y'all waited for
michael pachter to tell you again
so now y'all hear it right you hear it
now right he had to say doomed to you
and i told you before i want their games
and it's going to happen
all right so if y'all want to say oh
he's wrong most of the time well i'm
right most of the time and i said it
first you're going to respect me saying
it
and you're going to respect my 97
percent
no new playstation
it's over so
and just like alex said eldon ring
is gonna get game of the year
i think he owned or something all right
i think i'm on to something too
can't get his balls off i'm gonna
say what i gotta say that was a lot that
was a lot man preaching you don't look i
love that
pack is the homie i like pack you know
obviously the lord's better we have a
good relationship with him um
you know track record with industry
predictions is a little questionable um
look
i know where you're going
and i'm not it's not that i'm trying to
ignore tea leaves because i know what
you're doing and it's not what you're
saying
makes sense
the only reason why i disagree is if the
enemy is not adaptable
if the enemy like we're taking it back
right like if we we taking it back to
the sega days
there were signs
you need to adapt and they were not
adapting right there was a market
shifting on them right even nintendo
went through it a generation right they
were stubborn with cartridge cartridges
right they were stubborn with services
they were stubborn with third-party
support
and we saw it and then they go away and
sometimes you got to get your head bust
for you to learn that this is the way
the industry is going the difference
here is yes microsoft is ahead as far as
the future with the services the
streaming and i agree with pac on the
sense that right now
i'm with you the i call it like the
deluge when this thing starts hitting
with game pass like as far as
the consistency right there's a there's
going to be a period that even if let's
just say every and i
hate when i say that but let's just say
that so every sony banger
that's let's say they dropped two or
three a year and every sony banger is a
90 medical let's say every single one
it there comes a point when you have a
service like game passing only students
and they do start to hit let's just say
that everyone from microsoft is not a
nine let's say it's an 85.
at the end of the day even if a couple
of number 90s are all in the 85s
it becomes overwhelming because now it
becomes this quarterly monthly release
and then you're throwing game pass
things in it then you throwing deals at
that point you're literally jumping
sony's game right and i go i know where
you're going long term the only reason
why i say this is different
is because
the enemy is showing adaptability the
enemy is saying oh wait a minute this
god god thing ain't it
um we need to get on the phone azure we
we need to call you
and make this as you're getting that a
word sign that no that's adaptive
because to me it's like
bro that's
someone that that is the true ultimate
factor that they are adapting because
they called the competition to help with
that right so what happens when they
make the next phone call to get game
pass on it because it's such a success
that's adaptability i mean it is
it is it is it would be a detriment to
to their name
a doom not a dead tree a detriment but
to me doom is when doom is no way you
know what it would be a detriment it
would be a detriment to to the perceived
dominance of their name and all the
console war stuff that goes with it
right yeah to me let's say this the
company no longer has value no one wants
it okay that's not being sold anywhere
all right so let me let me give you my
my definition of deal all right
they are not how you perceive them to be
okay
mike listen mike tyson didn't cease to
exist
but he ceased to exist as the
heavyweight champion
you know and
i expect them to be
a developer a
third-party developer
i expect that to happen
because i expect the best from them is
their software because it's not their
hardware mm-hmm and when if i can see it
from the outside
the people in the building can see it
from the end
here's the difference where i think
you're losing track
their old model is still selling
and they're willing to work and do the
new model and their boss is so in keen
with phil spencer's practices you know
what i'm saying the generation talks
that was spartacus talk now it's cloud
talk
now you know like they are literally
utilizing the infrastructure that
microsoft is going to use understand for
them but the most important thing day
and date can they do that that's a good
point that's a good point that's the
most important that's an excellent point
that is when
they're going to do that
when the landscape drags that's what i'm
saying there's no need for them to adapt
on that yet because that would
definitely help save them now as far as
the amount of like the amount of games
that microsoft can release that's a
different story because when you have so
even if sony releases their games on
their game on the service the it won't
be enough to sustain that service all
year long that's why microsoft went out
and bought so many studios because they
needed enough content
yes my sony does not have that let's be
real like at all right they would have
to buy something like story he needs to
even remotely come close to me i don't
think they have to even with them i
don't think that the reason why i don't
think they have to imagine because we
look we not even talk about the elephant
in the room all this doom talk but
there's one company out here that ain't
on no service that is just making
quality and actually winning generations
it's nintendo you know so so at the end
of the day it still proves that if your
games are quality you don't have to do
that you still have this core base
that's willing to pay whatever you want
to play never have a discount and sony's
like yo our base is willing to pay 70
and we go up the price and until we see
failure there there's no need to go
adapt to this to the to the daily
like a lot of their
here's the thing like they're not the
standard console like they yeah they
they're they're hybrid when you go out
and you do like the holiday stuff you
can't just buy one if you've got
multiple kids right you gotta buy mobile
yeah because it's it's a hybrid yeah by
multiple games i agree i i do think that
it's a different way a mobile a mobile
console it's easier to sell in countries
that doesn't
i agree because if you look at like the
cells in japan versus the cells and with
playstation and nintendo like nintendo
is quadrupling and then doubling that
accordingly i feel you all i'm saying is
it for it to get to doom to me you have
to have multiple
failures like to me i'm not there where
i'm seeing
multiple failures
the thing about sony they did like i
said i was saying before it's just the
fact that their timeline is pushed up
because they don't have the luxury of
being seen as the outsider like nintendo
they they are you know in a lot of
people's minds they're the market leader
so they have to go toe-to-toe with their
direct competition so that's the thing
they don't have the timeline and the
luxury be like we're going to take our
time and see what see how this pans out
right like nintendo can like nintendo
obviously and shout out to hustle
because he mentioned in the chat right
like they have a subscription service
right it's not
remotely close to what the other two are
probably going to do but
they understand that something in that
vein they have to have something in that
vein even even if they're on the outside
but they they're the only ones that have
the luxury of being on the outside
because they're so different correct
playstation yeah they just can't like
even no matter how much they want to and
i get it until the wheels fall off and
people are like i'm not paying for your
70 game i don't care if it's the last of
us part three
when that happens that's when you really
be like okay right if we haven't put the
bricks in place to do it build something
different then we're in big trouble and
and the combination of if these games
that are only like kids as the bustle if
those continue to fail let's just say
like yo they actually start making duds
from things that we expect them to be
great
right yeah if god of war comes out and
it's not if that's what because now you
have
bad games that everyone's counting on
right then you you have this limited
release window they don't come out as
frequent right then you've got this
service that people like yo i'm not
paying 70 i'm gonna go over here right
and let's be honest microsoft this is
where king is right that's a domino
right microsoft has positioned himself
as the most consumer friendly console
period right
you you are just the game narrative
really all playstation has a lot exactly
because at the end of the day the common
folk that once the news gets out he go
to gamestop and it's like yo i could get
call of duty and all this and and in
this subscription service and this
little system for 300 and walk out right
now oh by the way you don't get the cash
you don't say oh you ain't gonna pay the
bill we could put you on this all access
program and you could just walk out
right now like that starts to add up to
the casual the casual is gonna win so i
understand what where where king is
going and he's not completely wrong for
his train of thought all i'm just saying
is with sony i need to see a little bit
more of these debacles so to speak and
the fact that they haven't had
the major failures yet like they haven't
had a no disrespect xbox crackdown three
moment
where this expected thing is they didn't
have a halo master chief collection but
with an expected thing just completely
like until they have those moments they
still gonna have that core base they may
not win the generation i'll still give
you that they i guess i can still win
the generation but they got to show me a
little bit more and the fact that
they're still
willing to adapt if they if they were
ignorant and stubborn and like we're not
doing cloud and we're not doing
subscription service and we're not then
i'm like um
you're not willing to change this tony
as long as sony continues to produce
games like last of us god of war and
continue to partner up with developers
that are producing games like last of us
such as like persona 5. uh they they're
going to be in the contender because of
those games now i will agree with with
king it's like right now
the mass majority of playstation 4 users
that's where the casual consumer will
right it is debatable they might lose
that yeah if they lose that that's a lot
of money that's out of place and this
and the pandemic has hurt them i will
give king now absolutely yeah can i say
something yeah go for a girlfriend real
quick real quick but until they lose
that aspect and they lose those games as
long as they make good games they'll be
relevant but it's like king said but
they can lose
the head macho where it's like everyone
goes to their platform because all their
friends are playing on it once they lose
that casual market then i would say
they're not going to be as relevant but
as long as they make games they'll be
relevant right good good yeah see ya
i understand what you're saying addicts
see but the thing with me those games
you name those great playstation
exclusives from god of water uncharted
to last of us all those games are
phenomenal but what do those games have
in common they all take five yeah or six
years to develop right so the casual
market those huge games like cod you
know the the sports games
there's a lot of people we all know that
all they buy
they they'll buy a ps5 just to play some
casual games um so
and those games uh you know like the ps4
sold 120 million consoles and still only
10 to 20 million
will buy those games even jim ryan
himself said that's not enough anymore
and their games are very expensive so
when it goes back to the point of day
and date that's the most important thing
in my opinion
for spartacus and i think
it's not going to be their date
i think the landscape would have to
drastically change like they would have
to be losing sales like two to one and
they would have to be losing every
every type of marketing right that they
possibly can
the amount
of stuff that would have to go before
they do that day and date but here's the
thing like they did invest in the
spartacus they did admit the playstation
now is it they need to do something else
they are setting themselves up now
michael pachter and king they're not
wrong
if they don't hit the button if they
continue to stay on the track and they
don't care and they're not looking left
and right and they're hitting every
train known to man and they're getting
hit every corner without adapting but in
my personal opinion we've seen them
adapt multiple times i don't think sony
would go that far and i don't think they
would be that stubborn to go out
and say we spent all this money on
something that we can't use to the way
we want to use it microsoft can we use
your services to me that's all you need
to hear to know that micros that sony
will bend the knee in terms of day and
date if it came to the point where that
was the only option they had left
and they and and they are going to bend
the knee in terms of day and date with
some of these multiplayer games they're
developing guarantees pc and then you're
going to see
and that's the other thing the fact that
they're even willing to do pc they they
have let's be honest they've been very
coy telling their base the truth about
their true intentions and that's why
it's like to me jim ryan
that's what i see them doing pete like
these think about this last generation
this is a this is
what i'm hearing
i love you guys oh lord i love each and
every last one of you
y'all coming to the realization
of what i've been saying and you're
reconciling it within your soul
because what you're saying is
if if if they do this if they do this
if this happens if this happens so that
means that y'all could see a scenario
that it does and all i can do is just
possible
smile to myself knowing
what i know
to be true the thing is though king is
like i can admit that sony is stubborn
in certain ways that that is a
possibility that they would feel like
they don't have to to abide by anything
but
but the thing is like i'm not going to
say there's no way they would i'm with
all of you
i'm with all of you
it doesn't sound you're going to fight
like hell
they still going to put that lion in the
net
you know they
the lion is out on that serengeti
the hunt is still going to get him
he gonna fight like that he would not
want to get in that bag
why are we going to scoop him up in the
mud he's coming like because it's so
funny i'm hearing y'all y'all saying
this and uh yeah they gonna spartacus
gonna come out
games is gonna go on pc oh god
they gonna put out their bangers shout
out to the bangers
what happens when all your stuff
mm-hmm he gets state of place he what
you're not seeing is
everything they doing is always
someplace else
it used to be state of plays
and they stuff was theirs it's a
different day it used to be
when they showed something you didn't
have to go say wait a second coming out
over there
it's a change there's a change it seems
right
this is the shift this is no this is
your shift
but what the the conversation is would
sony make those type of choices and they
are we're they're gonna they just but
they don't know but the thing is
they can't be in relevant
fight like hell but the other dude just
stronger
like he's swinging with all his mic and
then he's just he's just breaking him
down that's what you do he's your new
banger he landed it and he turns the
dude ahead and he's like but then he
keeps him with the volume when when
jason punches the dude's head off on the
roof
you remember that he was hitting jason
with all he got and he stood up
you're gonna see when day and date come
out that's when they're standing in
front of the juggernaut
we tried everything
and their head gonna still get popped
popcorn
right into this garbage can that jason
is hilarious this is this is the
difference between what king feels and
what we feel we feel if they adapt
they'll be okay and they'll live king
says they're going to adapt and they're
still nice
a horrible day
it's not even a fight for kids
i will admit that there is a good
possibility in the long run
that
let me just get audrey because he said
that the moment he coming for me to chat
he said that though i said that they
haven't had that moment this generation
like uh halo match chief cracked down he
said it's happening kid [ __ ] he's like
law breakers godzilla or order 86
again all lows is la not this generation
right second of all a lot of those are
not even their games like from uh from
the third party and then a lot of those
games people liked yeah and a lot of
people get in and and and that didn't
that do well i don't know i don't want
next they're not good
so that's what i'm trying to say like
they haven't had a double yeah
i don't think order 1886 is something
you can use either because i actually
feel like they should have doubled down
on order right they need to go back
yeah this generation god falls not dance
though people put god for us
they're missing yeah
they're missing it i'm talking about
sony first party studios in-house what
what what y'all are really understanding
is that third-party support keeps them
afloat oh for sure and again absolutely
for sure gives them the ability to throw
that one header yeah every so often what
happens when you removed
those punches those body shots the
multiplayer right you removed the body
shot from the fight
now you relying on that one hitter yeah
and this is i'm agreeing with you on
this part the part that the third party
and i'll give right back to you the
third party and the casual is going to
win the generation right and if the
third party and the casual is playing
the call of duties
you know what i'm saying and all these
major because let's be honest for the
most part right as much as we love
horizon and god of war and all that they
are not the sellers
that those major ones are from a massive
the casual guy is gonna pick up nba 2k
madden cod
every year right fifa don't that's what
the casual play now when once he's over
there and you've determined yourself as
the casual system oh okay yeah i'm gonna
try that god of warm a try okay cool
and that's absolutely that's what i know
you're foreshadowing right and the fact
that even if you know
like we looked at mlb the show whatever
or outright is whatever there's
something that's the new hotness it is
in game pass day and date that takes
away the energy from us like
it becomes a no brainer like why am i
going to pay 70 when i can get it over
here
and the thing is i don't think they can
recover
you see i don't think they have the bank
to recover i agree with you on that
but i will say that they are making cond
they're are they are doing things you
know they said that they're making more
multiplayer etcetera games they came out
and said that they're yeah they're doing
live service bro that's what i was like
they said that they're gonna they that
they're not gonna focus on buying more
studios they're doubling down on the
shoes they currently have no they just
they still say
no harm and
massive amounts of studios not like like
microsoft's thing was like we're going
to buy a good amount of stuff we're
going
we're going to buy studios that makes
sense for the most part when it comes to
us
and then we're going to double down the
other studios and we're going to work on
multiple yeah they buy bikes microsoft
buy cars yeah anyway look hey
that's fine that's what i love i get
what you got let me i just want to sneak
this i know we went super long i had to
be mentioned because they talked about
it we got it just broke or whatever the
perfect dark um director
um dan newberg is the initiative second
major design departure in the year
according to linkedin so according his
life profile he left um
it says uh newberg had worked at the
initiative for nearly four years was
previously a game director on the tomb
raider series the same studio which is
now collaborating on perfect dark and
then he says the perfect dog exit makes
marks the second major design departure
on the project in the past 12 months
potentially more than a year ahead of
the reboot's expected release and then
in february 20 2021 that's when this
other design director drew murray
announced that he left the initiative to
rejoin his former employer um insomniac
games murray cited personal reasons for
his decision to leave so the question
begins
is
perfect dark dune
is you know yeah yeah king yeah
what's going on now
the initial
what's going on with the initiative
i wouldn't say the doom but it's
concerning like it's it's an eye out
thing like it's something that
you have to see the product to determine
if the pr if it was going to be due
because of what was going on behind
closed doors people leave all the time
and i know for a fact from talking to
some of my developer friends that like
people might think that he's leaving
because he doesn't like the direction
that initiative or anything's going or
he doesn't like being the way they might
be treating him but people don't realize
the amount of money that's being thrown
around in this industry right now like
well this is the thing
this is the thing he doesn't have like
he left without a job
he doesn't have he's not doing anything
right now right
that that's what makes it weird
but no
not this guy personal reasons was the
first dude the first guy yeah dude
do we know that he doesn't like for all
he does not have a job yeah i mean has
he came out no no he hasn't come out and
said anything but usually when you leave
and you have something on the books but
i'll be able to talk about it later but
it was a couple weeks before the other
dude announced he went to insomniac like
he literally just stated that he left he
didn't he didn't say anything remotely
um when when our friend at 343 left he
didn't say he went to respawn for what
three weeks right right yeah it was a
while before he admitted negotiations
partner negotiations
look like
could this be a sign that something's
bad yes it can't i'm not willing to go
there until i see more of what's going
on i got to see the product that you're
going to like to play questions but i'm
i think that
we got to keep in mind the amount of
money that's being thrown out like
someone could have literally offered
this man a bag that he just couldn't
resist
and then he could hate it i don't know i
don't i don't know what's going on in
that man's mind but you know we got to
see the product or we got to see at
least gameplay like we got to see
something on perfect dart before we
stamp a doomed or not dude
title on it thank you no doubt you're
going doomed now dude
yeah this is the word you like like
let's go dirt which they got crystal
they got crystal dynamics they're
working on the game like say there's
turnover all the time in the game and if
you like like addict said we don't know
if he got offered the bag that he
couldn't resist
um i don't think it's time for a concern
yet okay um not yet
uh i do believe we like hopefully we'll
see the game this year uh in in action
um but you know i'm not really concerned
as of yet okay fair person solve concern
is it over what's up
i mean
what's concerning to me is that it's the
game's director right this is the this
is the person that is kind of second big
person second exactly so
for me when you talk about gaming
director it's the person that's in
charge
of
creating the
creating how how we're we as fans are
going to experience the game right how
is this game from moment to moment scene
to see him going to play out and he
doesn't do that by himself obviously
right there other people around him but
the core idea of what this game is going
to be
is kind of on this person's shoulders
and for them to walk away
it's just concerning about it so it
makes you think a couple of things is
are they so far along that that
direction has already been set and
they're just building out the game right
right that could be that could be the
case that's definitely possible and if
it's not the case
then yeah that is concerning because
it's one of those things like you know
with perfect art coming back perfect
dark has to align itself in a way that
is distinct from halo it's distinct from
any other sort of fps out there to me
they really have to focus on the spy
aspects of joanna dark while at the same
time making sure it's a great action
shooter so there's a lot of things that
go into making a perfect dark game
that's relevant in 2020 whatever it
comes out
so for me
it's concerning if that game is still a
ways off that's that's the way i feel if
they if they show it this year and
they're like coming you know first
quarter 2023 bet okay then it's safe to
assume that most of it is done already
right um if not
then yeah i'm a little more worried
about it shout out to erica beard he
said director's leaving mid-cycle is it
normal stop the cap chat
we ain't talking about a junior concept
artist he going in every time every time
someone has left a studio we have said
that that's concerning but we here's the
we don't know enough information we just
don't like yeah we we haven't even seen
game play on this game and another thing
is
we don't know like with the initiatives
the the structure that we assume that
right that we don't even know what game
director means within that structure
right because it's just weird
it feels like they do it a different
type of development totally different
yeah it feels like it but again i ain't
making it
yeah so king your bars and then i go
okay well you know during this pandemic
um
the workloads are uh distributed
differently
uh as uh the lead the head um
[Music]
sometimes you get burnt out that's true
you know how long has he been in this
industry
and sometimes you you need that mental
break you need that break maybe it was
taken away from his family maybe a lot
of things was happening we don't know
exactly what it is that makes people go
to work that day and say you know what
today's my last day
you know maybe something happened and he
looked over and said you know what i'm
gonna spend more time with with
this person because this person's
may not have that much time or whatever
may be or maybe that person is needing
his time
there's a lot of people in individuals
lives that need
time guidance maybe that work isn't that
important to what's more important to
the individual's life
so we don't know that so to speculate on
why somebody leaves a job at any period
of time
it's kind of funny
but i do it all the time so when
something happens no when something
happens at a sony situation listen i'm
i'm
defense force
yeah y'all thought y'all was going to
come to me and have me say oh doom and
dude
i'm going to tell you
my man needed a mental health hold on so
you know oh
sometimes you run a race and you need to
take a breather all right you know so um
they didn't say oh he left on bad terms
or anything like that well we don't know
what's going on and uh
like drew murray needed a mental break
and he wound up back at the summit
yeah but the bag is crazy the bag is
crazy
shout out the boss he said ah we see how
y'all see how it is to e um yeah what i
was gonna say though
is the streets are talking king they're
saying that you know could this point to
a bigger issue at microsoft well you
know what i'm gonna say the streets the
streets need to shut up
but why we can't be concerned about the
game studios speculating on what's going
on in that but you speculate about
playstation if you let's speculate about
xbox games and let me say that let me
say that when other people he was on the
platform
yeah i'm listen i'm not the playstation
defense fund hello you gotta pay for
that exactly okay i don't i'm i'm gonna
talk about them like the streets do but
over here my defense of said situation
is my man just needed a bro
i'm so glad you gave us the inside lie
that what happened listen you said
the other dude went to insomniac when he
took a break maybe insomniac called send
him flowers every day maybe insomniac
came over and he took him to the movies
maybe insomniac showed him that level of
care and he said you know what i'm
reinvigorated i'm back and my batteries
in charge
yeah and they said you know what and
what's here's a great bag and he said oh
my god all right you're gonna be happy
with me you're gonna be happy with me
you're gonna be happy with me i'm gonna
give you some i'm gonna get some inside
baseball thank you i'm gonna get you
gonna be happy all right so according to
the man clobrell salute to him he says
um dan newberger game director on
perfect dark has moved on from
initiative he was there for a good three
years and eight months i think i slowly
start to get the idea behind the
initiative it looks like it's basically
a studio that kicks off a project and
carries it through concept prototype and
full pre-production phases then carrying
it over to full production with the
assistance of another
studio that has the needed manpower in
this case crystal dynamics almost like
we built the foundation outsource and
then go and then he says
this also explains the staying small and
agile comment that initiative did make
and the studio's name which is literally
the initiative we initiate execute and
he says while i realize he definitely is
with you well i realized some people
will call doom and gloom over it again
it could potentially also mean the game
is further ahead than people think 2023
could be on the table so what's offset
could be on the table
and i will tell you this though if it's
20 23 that's a monster lineup for 20 and
if it's 20 23
do y'all really say the playstation
survive tell me there you go all right
set your mind cause you this i i helped
you too much i helped you too much
anyway that was
anyway this is so hilarious how we cap
for what we like but anyway
moving on you gotta get
so let's do that actually why you why
are you lining that up shout out to
ebonses 2024 2025 yeah closing the
window now i see you you guys even
though y'all didn't get to the five
t-shirts in the files yeah it's just
move i'm still listening i'm still gonna
stream the game on wednesday for the two
and a half hours like i did last week on
my twitch show hello you're doing the
lawyers let y'all see what type of piece
you're dealing with
so look let's get to the poll question
while soft gets the super chats ready um
new ilp poll when you hear reports of a
developer departing a game studio
when do you think there is cause for
concern
the choices are a very concerning
especially when multiple developers
leave the project early or when the game
has not been released b
not concerned the industry is very fluid
and there are many personal reasons that
dev could leave that doesn't doom the
quality of the game or c i don't care
y'all just mad when y'all favorite dev
leave with a bigger bag with the ops
suit to everybody
rock it
to the chat salute to everybody who got
that powder today yo a lot i love cold
330 iron 30 vs gg.com go get that sour
son go get that sour go get your shaker
go do what you got to do it's the last
day up for the cold you see my advanced
gg brother is up in the chat ibontista
cheetah you already know that's my dude
and that's my advantage you partner and
bro
yeah yeah you got to get in the raid
with them arms solve you want to get the
super chats
yes sir make sure no nothing else to pop
down no doubt no
flame said vote for c and cog will deal
powder in your streets
powder
powder continue
we got dragon heart yobe 5 super chat
peace love life rumors going around that
the ppp loans are ramping up again
expect to see free r kelly sooner than
later
dick's call pushing powder on the lord's
day evan this hashtag push your father
when you outside baby let's get that
sour we out here legal way
i can take it
and we got
otaku five dollars a paycheck
playstation as we know them is doomed
because they're going to be owned by a
bigger company in 10 years
that can happen too remember i said it
netflix
netflix yeah okay
that can translate into movies seriously
yeah money last of us remember they
signed them for eight seasons unheard of
crazy we got x abbott five dollars which
when i saw this pactor quote i figured
he got his analysis notes from king
they cheated notes he watched he watched
that's my mansion
i got his back all day there we go hard
geeks five dollars for chat factor is
basing that on some realities in the
market sony didn't decide to change
playstation now to something new out of
nowhere they see it as well yeah that
means they they don't know man y'all
just gonna listen later hear me now
then we have
called weed ten dollars if you chat i
saw so many comments on called weeb
i saw so many comments on twitter saying
that sony is the market leader and
doesn't have to compete with microsoft
history is littered with companies with
that kind of hubris yeah you can't
afford to have the hubert turbo graphics
pc engine
buy now
argentine once again ten dollars for
chat can someone tell me why playstation
is the market leader why do they lead it
what do they oh sorry what do they leave
console sales nintendo is nintendo
largest ips nintendo largest number of
studios microsoft most sold game of all
time minecraft highest measure
i guess the list goes on the list goes
up
there we have eternal shaddai five
dollars for chat destiny is playstation
savior just by picking up bungie they
just created their own fate of being
doomed oh my
[Laughter]
[Music]
five dollar super chat profit savings on
it again monopoly issue is game pass not
single ips like cod that is true yo no
they didn't make a space is why cognito
should play el dorado
and what they should have did was they
should have put the code link in make
you buy anybody
anybody
they don't understand the rules
cog for the streets baby that's it baby
you gotta expand your horizons you know
they didn't come to hampstead then they
ain't getting it
[Laughter]
let's go
blockbuster was popular and they still
died sony could be in trouble if they do
not pivot just because of lo just
because as lord saab said the
competition can do things that sony
cannot and they need to be
careful it's very true pivot all they
like
running right into their right hand
[Laughter]
then we got taiye casares with the 80
super chat thank you so much
the reason i think sony is doomed is
their decision to focus on multiplayer
games which isn't their strength it's
that single player experience that they
sell
it's why they sell they did so well last
gen xbox is forcing them into a corner
and they hold on
and they chose wrong i don't think
they're doing one to the exclusion of
the other i don't really think that you
could do both i don't understand why
they just never did they've never wanted
to do both but i got it no choice but
you two now
exactly
then we got called weave again five
dollar super chat sony may be willing to
adapt but a lot of their hardcore base
isn't that's just fanboys
remember the cross generational joint
yeah
okay i bent the knee i got the chainsaw
upstairs remember
you can come over i'll record it we're
gonna bust it open pause
the thing the thing is like
like even if you take the entire entity
of like fanboys on the playstation side
like it's it's a minority yeah they're
they're yeah they're a lot of them
minority yeah it's a loud minority
[Music]
but at the end of the day like i don't
think they amount like if they about it
to anything then the people that said
that you're not gonna buy these because
they're putting it on pc the sales were
to dramatically fall and they didn't so
well they 13 you know they they platinum
13
yo that's the 13th
guy right here
i'm dirty i love it i love
it so
to finish out of that super chat how
many of them still think pc ports the
value of the ps5 how many bad services
yeah i mean it's true
i'm saying that mm-hmm
that's a loud minority
[Laughter]
then we got mad 410 10 super chat sony
can bounce back on multiplayer with the
revival of the socom series i if socom
comes back that game is day and date in
spartacus guaranteed
and that thing if it's stink like a
brick yellow
that's probably on that's like low key
that's probably on pc day one too that's
right as well yeah shout out to nixon
definitely you're working
they hired a hitter
hey yo
that's it
if the initiative is a small team that
only builds the concept and framework of
the game and then passes it to a bigger
studio and i don't see a concern of him
leaving after that's already done that's
the point
that's the vision if that is the case
god bless i'm out now we got kushik
taluk dar two pound super chat solving
you good sorry about your card know how
it feels i'm good brother i'm good
for the checklist
so it's a violation but you know he was
off when he was he was calling uh
hungry
have a great week fellas you as well my
brother
then we have
don otaku five dollar super chat
nintendo's the only platform with top
tier single player and multiplayer
exclusive games and ips sony and
microsoft playing catch-up hashtag
nintendo
i don't know
i mean i guess
what i mean dude come on man he was on
one he was on one
look
everybody on revenue i gotta give it to
smash right i got a mario kart i gotta
give it to those dude two games
congratulations
so that's that's what happens
let's go let's go
oh
it's five dollars super challenge
marguerite and i'm buying him a fine
dining steak dinner listen don't listen
to eggs make sure you get the powder
though that's we're moving it but don't
listen to eat these margaritas
and make sure you put a one on your damn
steak your healing
000 shout out to the lords and missed
and dirt i was going to say mr dirt and
dirt
yeah
my boy calal passed away and that hit me
hard tick was the podcast that brought
me into the community wrestling priest
brothers
look man everybody that makes it
absolute man again but we gotta salute
the man who rocked with us for damn near
five hours didn't complain didn't leave
did i'm shocked man salute to you
brother
ray tracing
right tracing baby shout out to the dirt
man this was an absolute fun episode i
mean he brought it in super chat yeah we
get the super chat we'll get to jake
you know what i'm saying but yeah salute
to you brother where can the fine people
find you what you got going on man uh
first off man i just want to thank you
guys for this invite uh you know
i had a bar brother i had a boy actually
these four and a half hours kind of flew
by man you know
you know uh so thank you guys for
inviting me on it was a great uh yeah so
check out my channel um
doug griggity
uh you know i have a podcast on monday
evenings called wbz azbots podcast we do
talk a lot of trash
uh mostly geared towards playstation
fanboys but we also talk news we talk
gaming news and we have a good time
fellas uh ladies fellas and also you
know i i do my regular little seven
eight minute videos about maybe two to
three a week it depends on how the news
is popping so let's stop by y'all uh
putting the channel in the chat y'all go
go sub go check them out
thank you i appreciate this
video is hilarious thank you man i
appreciate it no doubt it was salute
salute to him man it's like the wpg the
homies everybody they pulled up for you
bro they pulled up and again shout out
to attic for um asking the community who
we want to get new voices and dirk was
top i might put
yeah dirk was top of the list man it's
always good to pay it forward you
already know oh lord addict uh we got
anything else going on with you sir
um
[Music]
oh dude my green screen's already
closed up shots
closed up
when the green screen's up i feel
extremely claustrophobic
like sitting here for four and a half
hours with that anxiety i was like i
couldn't keep that listen
right now
yeah i'll be putting it in there i think
i will step off a little bit i
appreciate you guys
keep in mind uh i i will
be appreciate you meeting up with the
lords because we we we do owe you a
community tonight
one of those um
we owe you a community night and we also
owe you a uh a round table uh podcast
yeah answer your question what are you
gonna say at
i'm going to go see it again with the
kids too i'm going to take my sons to
see it hang out with um
so
be on the lookout for that i definitely
catch me on the attic show on this
channel that you're currently watching
this this uh tuesday at 5 00 p.m with uh
my co-host hustle and me
uh you know last week well we actually
reacted to that horrible state of play
that they had in mind
but you know it was dope for game pass
so
keep in mind we
i appreciate everyone coming through
here you know
we you guys came in here
crazy you know uh king will be uh live
streaming uh eldon ring when are you
gonna do that king what time wednesday
um usually wednesday i go live after i
get home uh probably like around like
one o'clock whatever but but i'm gonna
do it for the two and a half hours like
i did last time so um i'll i'll say it
on my spill but yeah hopefully ada could
jump in and we'll be acting a fool again
you know how we do me and him like you
know no doubt in cash
cash yeah man these dudes will be
knowing these representatives
love that movie
that's it
yeah that's it i'm gonna go get
something yeah i'll be able to eat all
right
look slow down this motor then gave out
let's start with five he'll find you
what you got going on sir no doubt big
shout out to dirk griggity one of my
favorite names to say ever on the
podcast no doubt
my favorite um yeah so now i shout out
to you brother and everything you're
doing oh yeah i know i'm never around
but you don't that you send that invite
my way i'll figure it out for sure
i know i'm never here but you know
you know what's funny when it comes to
the attic show i never asked saul
because i know i know he's not gonna
have
facts
[Music]
and of course the king in full effect
moving into groovin out he had his tag
team partner harlem heat was in there
too too much ray tracing for me today i
could not deal with it
listen man it was it was messy but it
was funny it was funny salute salute to
you gig what you got going on me
well first and foremost uh dirt man
i i said before when y'all send me the
the the invite i couldn't say yes fast
enough
you know um and i was definitely there
full effect it was dope we had a dope
show we're gonna do it again i like i
said i love your energy love the story
where you know
the stories are classic
with what what started the ball rolling
on a divorce
downhill after that brother i like that
she called the pastor in the moment
right there she was like we got to we
got to get him
inside the house it's a situation and
you know then you sitting there looking
at her like you really called the pastor
yeah you know that's great you should
call my mama first oh yeah yeah
mama first yeah man i said what was
wrong with you
i don't know about these games though
crazy it's real life you don't get it
you don't get it i can play a video game
inside a video game inception you don't
know about that that's right done
yo but
i had so much fun today and i knew we
would i knew we were coming into this
because i love your energy i love your
show so if y'all not subscribed then
please go over there and subscribe to
him right now go get that done this
wednesday y'all can follow me on my
twitch channel that's uh king david ot
no king david iop on twitch
my my avatar is up there so if you don't
see me that's not it go find it till you
see me
um
dcx
fridays at 9 00 p.m we catch a couple of
thousand years mingling with some
millionaires talking about these
thousand dollar statues that you see
around me
um
big moves stuff happening yes kos is
coming we got some stuff happening in
dallas check your email
um
and we got a combat talk with the king
we got earl spence coming up and he's
about to fight oogaz um that will
probably be when i will do the next
combat talk and combat talk is live all
this stuff is changing we got stuff
working and moving in the background
shout out to everborn saga that's my guy
um
and you can find me on twit i mean on
twitter
why i'm out here having so much fun with
these dudes it's been quiet y'all don't
bother me no more y'all don't add me no
more
i'm feeling like jason voorhees now like
i'm i have to go hunt you down because
y'all guys are being too quiet i got to
make noise so if i catch y'all out here
you know what it is the work is going to
get in but today was a great messy show
thank you so much for allowing me to be
messy
anyway look man fantastic show okay
real quick um now how we're going to do
the community night
is i'm going to
i'm going to post in the members
uh and i'm going to post in the patreon
now you guys will give us suggestions on
what game we want to play uh we will
take four of those games that all four
of us agree we'll stream and we'll let
the whole uh the whole realm community
pick on twitter but the people that will
be picking the games ultimately will be
the members and patreons uh i will be
posting that sometime today uh so keep
that in mind and i i do have one thing
real quick okay after the podcast has
ended but my friend jamaican gamer man
he's over there streaming call of duty
and i love for you guys to pop in there
and uh show him some love he he grinds
so hard and he's got nine people in
there man let's let's knock that up a
little bit anyway so look salute um
shout out to hockey shitty those are
three stickers the three stickers don't
count then we say pack shirts right we
gotta get new packs no it's it's
everything oh so i i didn't see you i i
heard pastors he got the three and we in
that's what i heard so i don't know
about that i gotta read the five prayers
i don't know how this you gotta review
your your submission don't know just yet
we gotta speak to the brain trust
no
anyway we will figure it out we will
figure it out but look everybody salute
everybody pull it up fantastic show
again dirk held it down so much fun all
jokes aside with it with everything um
really appreciate the support obviously
kind of one of our first sponsorships
with the whole advanced gg the powder
jokes and all that but salute man it
really means a lot to us and we're
looking to do bigger and better things
get ready to see y'all at pax if y'all
pulling up we're going to get some
what's up
some super chats
gotta read the super chat and then like
i said salt fall research but also again
it's the last thing all jokes say last
time to get that powder for 30 off go in
there go get that use the cold iron 130.
it's up there after that it'll be just
iron lord 10 percent off so rock that
when you can i was getting some chances
that was rolled
but we got donald taco five dollar super
chat animal crossing mario kart smash
platoon outselling any multiplayer games
with xbox the playstation stop the cap
shut up gary barwick ten dollars
nintendo's first because they're the
babysitter of the consoles turn it on
and forget your children exist for a
while that's kind of true
then we got r b aka underground gamer
steak blasphemy medium rare steak with
blue teas on top is top tier wbg sanders
regards nintendo fans are on that fbi
watch list
medium rare with blue cheese the media
is a panel member on the show
i'm sorry listen even that's blasphemy
medium rare watch your own peppa that's
it
watch your arteries man
that's true too that's true too
then we got barry warwick again which if
nintendo was a band it would be the
wiggles
wow remember that wow
you got kids you know who the wiggles is
baby yeah
then we got donald taku 500 it's sad
that we still have insecure men who have
to discredit games that don't make them
feel like that testosterone is flowing
wow okay i must must be a nintendo fan
but i i play super lucky's tale so shout
out to me yeah
that game was fired i finished it too
this game was fired then we got my games
got tails
[Laughter]
kaiju five dollar super chat made it
home just in time to do this for the
lords and dirt for a great show ps
thanks to king for them 10k merch
hashtag hey king hey take this out
you've been trolling me forever yeah he
bought this shirt and he put it up on
twitter too he put the take aj
so look it looked like her geek should
he bought three stickers
he did that to me he did he the one that
did it to me
remember
yeah
oh wow tyree casares eight dollar super
chat cog we selling that powder better
than any dealer i know listen bro powder
get that sour get that sour y'all know
what it is get your shakers iron 30 go
out there baby because then we're moving
we outside baby look again salute
everybody enjoy your sunday appreciate
y'all y'all we're gonna hit y'all with
that last promo and we out please watch
that cognito here iron law podcast
logicgaming.net here to talk to you
about advanced gg your boy has partnered
with advanced gg one thing about me i
know i promote a healthy lifestyle about
gamers getting to the gym gamers doing
stuff earning the right to game i've
always been on that type of thing and
i'm very particular with what i put in
my body so shout out to fursy monsters
my last word co-host you know what i'm
saying and of course khakis hd is
another one and you know i'm a very
particular they've been kind of repping
the product for a while i've been taking
it for about over about a year and i
have to admit product is absolutely
fantastic
you know when it comes to those long
gaming sessions your boy probably
rocking that focus you know what i'm
saying doing them yeah i wonder how [ __ ]
doing them six hour raids he probably
took some focus before him and then
obviously you know with the gym you know
your boy has to get in there i have to
earn the right to game in order to do
that i usually rock that energy shout
out to that birthday cake absolutely
delicious but um i've been rocking with
the party for a while you know i'm fully
transparent shout out to the entire team
they've been a pleasure to work with and
um run yourself right now
to
advancedgg.com
put in code iron lord 30 on the checkout
that's advanced gg.com iron lord 30 and
get yourself some advantage try to
product out it's absolutely delicious
been rocking for about a year and it's
again full transparency on the label you
get a lot of the information straight up
no gimmicks look if he bounces like it
and that man don't put condiments on his
food you know he worried about what he
put in his body so you know i did my
research
all jokes aside man shout out to vseg
again iron lord 30 your boy the lords
have partnered up
check it out support healthy healthiest
wealth support a healthy lifestyle go do
that thing let's
download to the website go check it out
whether you're going to get that focus
for the gaming session the energy a
little perk for the gym we want to get
some swag some merch maybe a ice shaker
go right on over there check out the
products but again really cool products
they don't hide behind any type of
proprietary blend
nonsense it's all transparent as far as
the ingredients the label green tea
caffeine kind of a healthy form of
natural caffeine none of that crash none
of that stuff so yeah again go check it
out you run in there you add it to your
cart use that referral link that we got
in the description and then you make
sure on the checkout you're putting in
iron lord again iron lord on the
checkout get yourself a nice discount
when you're checking out advanced gg and
like i said try the product for yourself
see what you think about it the lords we
love it and we are powered by advanced
gg so check